hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we are going to be going over the
most hype arc in all of demon slayer
this arc starts off in one of the
literally most insane ways and
constantly blew me away like every
single time i thought that it was at its
peak i went straight into the discord
and started discussing it with the boys
link in the description by the way
thinking that it possibly couldn't
ascend to an even higher degree of just
god tear story but it fantastically
somehow did this thing that constantly
had me scrolling through page upon page
and chapter upon chapter was nothing
else than the one and only infinity
castle arc of the beautiful demon slayer
story so without any further delay make
sure you hit that subscribe button and
leave a like on the video as it really
goes to show that you are really loving
these demon slayer explain videos but
anyway enough of that let's get into
part one of the final arc of kamitsu no
yaiba
muzan kibitsuji a demon the yubiyashiki
family and the demon slayers had been
chasing for a thousand years has finally
come kagaya who is now completely unable
to see because of his illnesses asks his
wife amane for his descriptions
muzan on the other hand mocked him as he
who they have been chasing showed no
signs of aging while kagaya on the other
hand is already smelling like a corpse
it was then revealed that muzan and
kagaya are actually from the same family
which lead to the ubishiki family being
cursed where every child born will be
weak and die right away in order for
their family to not die out the ubishiki
family dedicated themselves in defeating
and have received wives from their
priests for generations which made them
resilient but nobody in their family was
able to live beyond the age of 30 years
old
upon hearing this muzan ridiculed him as
even with all their efforts and even
with the thousands of people killed by
muzan he has never been punished kagaya
however questions him about his dreams
which make muzan uncomfortable who also
notes that there are only four humans
presence in the mansion kagaya his wife
and two children who are currently
playing nearby muzan's dream is to be
indestructible and it will come true
once he gets his hands on nezuko but
kagai was able to turn the ridicule on
muzan and his dream stating that it will
not come true he continues recalling how
the demon hunters still exist and have
existed and never died out for over a
thousand years kagaya tells muzan that
he is going to prove to him that human
thoughts are indestructible and the
thought of never forgiving those who
have taken the lives of people's loved
ones away senselessly is eternal telling
him that not once has he ever been
forgiven over the past 1000 years he
always proceeded to step on the tiger's
towel constantly finally now incurring
the wrath of the dragon he has just
awoken further noting that even if he
dies the hunters will not feel any pain
as they do not need him that much the
connection to human thought is something
that demons cannot understand because
they will cease to exist once muzan dies
upon hearing this muzan becomes enraged
and appearing in front of kagaya he
demands him to be quiet in which kagaya
retorts instead thanking him
as muzan goes to grab pagaya it flashes
away to a nearby crow rocketing through
the forest and informing the hasheras
along with the demon hunters of the
attack on the ubiyashiki estate in a
previous hashera meeting tsunemi draws
attention to the problem of kagaya being
unguarded believing to her shearers in
the least need to be protecting him he
and the others ask yomma if something
can be done to change this problem gyome
having known kagaya the longest only
responds that he had been asking the
same question for eight years and kakaya
had always denied his protection he
insisted someone like the hashera
shouldn't be wasted on someone like
himself worrying them shinobu adds that
she heard the ubiyashikis had never had
a bodyguard of sorts throughout their
history back in the action saneemie
hurries through the forest towards the
ubishiki estate as he catches sight of
the mansion a massive explosion destroys
the mountainside to sunimi's sheer
horror the explosion is noticed by the
rest of the hashera horrifying them all
tangido realizes the sense of blood and
burning flesh is in the air
muzan caught directly by the explosion
tries to regenerate and curses kagaya in
his final moments kagaya had the smile
of a buddha before killing himself
alongside his wives and two daughters
the demon lord never believed he was
capable of such commitment towards
killing him and underestimated him
adding he nukagai had planned something
but nothing at this scale he notices
kagaya even added spikes to the
explosions to delay his regeneration
even further muzan senses that kagaya
has something else planned knowing
people and most likely her sharers must
be close by he thinks back to the
oyukatsu's final moments he had hid all
his anger and bloodlust without muzan
even noticing something he begrudgingly
commends him for as muzan tries to put
his mind towards regenerating quicker
flesh seeds appear around him without
warning they burst into gigantic black
branches he realizes that there must be
some sort of blood demon r but is
completely immobilized the spikes don't
harm him however and muzan believes he
can simply absorb them to escape out of
nowhere though tamiya appears and stabs
her hand through muzan's stomach muzan
is angered at her sudden appearance and
asks her reason
tamiu mentions the flesh seeds belong to
the man in asakusa he turned into a
demon he realizes she must have hidden
herself with another blood demon art
using yushira's talismans she tells
muzan the drug in her first absorbed by
him turns demons back into humans though
muzan claims that it's impossible but
she states it became possible with
someone's help muzan curses her
stubbornness and makes the claim that
her hatred of him is unjust he reminds
her that she alone was responsible for
the death of her family she definitely
responds all she wanted was to survive
her disease and see her children grow up
but the demon lord mentions she had
eaten other people after that and states
she had fun doing so tamiyo doesn't deny
that fact and states that in order to
atone for those deaths she and muzan
will die together tamiya calls out to
gyome the first to arrive at the scene
and with a single swing of his spiked
flail he decapitates mu's arm
at the young age of just 23 kagaya
ubishiki is confirmed to be dead before
his death he spent every day visiting
the graves of fallen demon slayers till
his affliction finally prevented him
from doing so gomi recalls the first
time he met kagaya when oyakata was 14
and he himself was only 18 immediately
kagai knew that gyome had protected the
children he was accused of killing
germain remembers even back then kagai
spoke in a way that people wanted to
hear and his solemnness remained to his
last moments during the last time he
personally spoke with the stoneheshira
kagaya predicts that muzan kibitsuji
will come within five days instructing
gyomay to decapitate him as kagaya acts
as the decoy himself it is then revealed
that the ubyashiki's family's way were
foresight and instinct was unmatched
using their power to protect themselves
from disasters kagaya knows the other
hasheras would not accept his decision
of self-sacrifice and asks the hesherah
he is known for the longest to carry out
his wish gyomi manages to successfully
be hed muzan assisted by tamiyo keeping
the demon still as kagaya had predicted
muzan regenerates his head completely
unsurprising to gyome he recalls his
late leader's words that sunlight is the
only way to kill the demon lord and he
resolves to keep him restrained till
dawn
muzan attempts to ensnare the hashera
with blood demon art black blood
brambles but the attack is only
deflected by gyome's stone-breathing
third form stone skin tsunemi arrives
and angrily asks what has become of
kagaya the rest of the hashera then
arrive asking each other about their
leader's state yermy announces that they
are now facing muzan himself to the
shock of all the hashera as none of them
have ever directly encountered him
tanjido the only one present who has
personally faced him angrily calls out
to him all of the remaining hashera use
their respective breath techniques in
order to cut muzan down as they converge
on the demon museum laughs to himself
giant doors suddenly appear and slide
open under the demon slayers causing
them all to plummet into the infinity
castle and he declares that he will kill
them all tonight tangerine responds back
though that the only one who is going to
die will be muzan muzan answers his
challenge telling him to do it if he can
as tanjuro falls he is caught by geyu
and thrown onto a nearby platform to
safety the two are suddenly attacked by
numerous demons but quickly kill them
all using the water breathing sixth form
whirlpool and water breathing third form
flowing dance respectively tangero
comments on how amazing gee you is
internally noting how he can accurately
predict the type of form he would use
through slight movements all the while
staying unnerved the two then head out
further into the castle obernau rescues
mitsuri from several demons using
serpent breathing fifth form slithering
serpent much to her exuberant gratitude
gyome and muchiro rush throughout the
castle slaughtering demons they note all
the demons they encounter are roughly
the strength of a lower moon suggesting
muzan intends to wear them down the two
lament the loss of kagaya yubi ashiki
mature remembers the time he was near
death from attacks and kagaya
encouraging him to continue
kagai did so with all of the injured
demon slayers in a fatherly manner
maturo seethes with rage that muzan had
killed his twin and his second father
and hopes to bring him to hell something
the normally calm gyome furiously hopes
to do also sunimi laments his inability
to protect kagaya when demons appear
before him he rapidly slaughters them
all
inosuke is excited falling into the
infinity castle eager to test his
abilities on numerous demons zenitsu
hears something nearby and believes a
particular someone is close calling them
unforgivable
shinobu smells some blood and decides to
open up a nearby door inside the room
are numerous corpses of woman and a
demon standing there
ashinobu remembers kane kocho's death
she is seen crying and kane tells her to
quit the demon slayer court she tells
her to gain the happiness of a normal
girl and to live until she became old
shinobu desperately asks her sister
about the demon that attacked her
stating that she could not live a normal
life like this
sadly the flashback ends with shadow
recalling that it was a demon that
looked like blood was dumped all over
his head as she witnesses a demon devour
his victims while surrounded by female
corpse strewn about the demon smiles and
takes off his crown introducing himself
as doma shinobi recalls her sister's
words that the demon would laugh in a
carefree manner and would talk softly
one of doma's victims reaches out
desperately for help only to be told by
doma to be quiet as he was in the middle
of talking however shinobu carries her
away from doma and sweetly asks whether
she is all right to which doma asks
whether she was a hashera due to her
speed just as the victim attempts to
reply to shinobu she is murdered by
doma's attacks doma smiles and tells her
to leave the body there stating that he
will eat it later shinobi remembers what
her sister had stated the demon's
weapons were a pair of sharp fans the
demon then explains that he was the
leader of the eternal paradise faith
claiming that it was his duty to be
happy with himself and his followers but
shinobu tells doma disgustedly that the
girl he had killed was clearly in pain
and begging for help to this he responds
that he had saved the girl claiming that
she no longer feels pain suffering or
fear doma then goes on to say that
everyone fears death which is why he
eats his followers for their sake so
that they can live forever with him
he claims that he takes his followers
hopes blood and flesh to heart and leads
them to a higher salvation but shinobu
angrily spits that he couldn't possibly
be sane and asks whether he is all right
in the head telling him that he makes
her want to vomit derma gives a
surprised expression noting that she has
been rather harsh for their first
meeting he then realizes that shinobi
must have been through something quite
difficult pitying her and suggesting he
listens to what she has to say about it
shinobu angrily clutches her heyori and
growls that doma was the one who had
killed her sister fiercely demanding if
he has no memories of this specific
kaori doma then recalls kanae as the
girl who used the flower breathing
stating his regret over not being able
to eat her before sunrise shinobu cuts
him off the strike to his eye with her
insect breathing dance of the beasting
true flutter doma compliments that it
was so fast he couldn't prevent it with
his hand
he then unleashes his demon art frozen
lotus and shinobu backflips and dodges
however she inhales some of the ice
powder that he had scattered about doma
compliments that she was fast but he
states that she wouldn't be able to kill
a demon with stabs and the slicing of
the neck was the best option to go with
to this she never responds that if a
stab wound didn't kill him poison would
just as the wisteria poison goes into
effect he falls onto the floor and hacks
up blood telling shinobu that this
poison was much stronger than the one
she had used at the mountain saying that
muzin had warned him that she changes
her poisons for every demon she faces
doma quickly breaks down the poison
widely grinning as he apologizes that he
has broken down the poison even though
she had gone to the effort to use it on
him he comments that shinobu's katana
made a distinctive sound whenever she
sheaths her he wonders aloud if that's
how she changes the concentration of the
poison he clasps his hands together and
joyfully exclaims how it was fun and
interesting to get poisoned and how it
may become a sort of habit he asks
shinobu whether she thinks the next
poison formulation would work excitedly
asking for her to try it out shinobu
notes though that it was already
speculated beforehand that he would most
likely be able to break the poison down
the miracles past and his childhood born
with rainbow colored eyes and white hair
he was believed to be special and
connected to god his parents whom he
considered stupid arranged a cult with
him at the head called the eternal
paradise cults worshipers flock to doma
to repent their issues and problems in
life hoping for advice doma however had
no feelings and found it problematic
that adults had seeked wisdom from a
child when they begged him to guide them
to paradise he cried believing paradise
gods and buddhas was all a fairy tale
that never even existed confused why
people wouldn't believe that they're all
just destined to die and rot doma
believed that it was his duty to make
these people happy durma then notices a
fifth slash on his hand and heals
himself of shinobu's poisoning asking
she is okay now that she has started to
breathe heavily shinobi realizes the
true strength of the upper rank noting
doma's resistance and the inability of
the poisons to work on him doma notes
shinobu's lungs must be destroyed having
taken a blow of his blood demon
technique she realizes the fog of his
frozen blood is hazardous of breathed in
and decided to use multiple blows to
poison him again using her insect
breathing dance of the dragonfly
compound i hexagon shinobi rushes
forward and stabs doma multiple times
thomas states that he believes the
insect heshira might be the fastest one
but as she backs away shinobu bleeds
profusely realizing she herself was also
hit in return
derma taunts her mentioning that she
could have easily cut off his head with
her immense speed but can't due to a
small frame as blood falls on her hands
she remembers how small they actually
are remembering that she'd never grown
any taller in her childhood she laments
she could have killed demons the usual
way if she had grown more she never
knows larger hands and legs meant more
muscle and that it was a distinctive
advantage she recalls kane was able to
do so despite only being slightly taller
and also with a dainty and thin frame
she remembers kane's last moments with
her telling her that she would likely
lose to doma kane's spirit suddenly
appears before the injured shinobu
telling her to stand shinobi believes
that she can no longer though heavily
bleeding and with her left lung shredded
by doma's fog she can't breathe normally
as well
kanye declares that irrelevant and
states that she will win with the right
resolve to kill him no matter the
sacrifice noting that she promised to
her and kano remembering their younger
sister shinobi crouches down while doma
approaches her noting the slash he gave
her was only half-hearted but it must be
painful for her kane urges her younger
sister to keep trying causing her to
stand which shocks the upper moon as she
stares at doma shinobu starts to cough
up blood prompting doma to laugh that
the blood in her lungs is causing her to
do so resolving to end her pain he tells
her to give up saying she is already
beyond saving kenobi takes a stance and
using her insect breathing dance of the
centipede hundred-legged zigzag she
speeds towards the upper ranked demon
doma becomes shocked at this feat noting
the destroyed bridge from the impact of
her feet's force doma tries to slash you
back but is just too slow only managing
to hit her cave shinobu crouches down
and launches into the air driving her
sword through doma's neck and forcing
his body into the ceiling and one final
thrust
shinobi remembers her childhood
believing that happiness was an endless
road throughout life that belief though
was shattered when a demon entered her
home and killed both of her parents
leaving her and kane orphaned they were
saved however by gyoume who quickly
defeated the killer shinobi realises
that her happiness was forever destroyed
other people's wound and resolved to
defeat demons and prevent other people
from suffering the same fate as her
shinobu and kane promised to each other
to both become demon slayers to do so
the two believed that despite their weak
strength stopping one demon could save
tens of people and stopping an upper
rank could save hundreds recalling the
time when tangier asked if she was angry
she states that she has been angry for a
long time remembering her parents death
her sisters and those of all of her
successes
she remembers aoi sumi keo and naho and
how their families were killed also most
of all she's incensed that her poison's
inability to hurt doma her sword slips
from doma's neck causing her to fall
doma however uses his ice to catch her
and pull shinobu into a hug the demon
carefully congratulates her for making
it thus far while mocking her for being
weak and less talented than kane to her
fury doma acknowledges her foolishness
at trying to kill him despite all of the
odds and calls it the thing that makes
humans so fleeting as he decides she is
finally worthy of being eaten by him
doma asks her for her final words and
what shinoba responds telling him to go
to hell kanoa opens up the door of the
cult room and looks up to see doma
clutching shinobu near the roof as she
watches doma breaks shinobu's body in
his arms takana was horror killing her
and causing her sword to fall from her
hand kanoa desperately leaps upwards to
use flower breathing fourth form crimson
hana goromo but misses when doma escapes
and lands onto the floor the demon
advises her not to attack him in the
middle of absorbing someone causing
kanua to seethe with rage doma fails to
taunt her and instead finally recalls
that shinobu only had a short time with
him due to his abilities and decides
that this night might be really good
having two gorgeous meals at once all
while licking shinobu's hairpin sinetsu
approaches a room and calls for the
being inside to come out
they only respond that zenichu's
beckoning is the improper address to a
senior kaigaku walks out and taunts him
for being as dainty and as seedy as ever
zenitsu responds back however that as a
demon kaigaku is no longer his senior
as tanjiro and geru continue through the
castle the former nearly falls through
an open floor commenting that the
building is seemingly trying to separate
the two while wondering how long tamiya
can withstand muzan and unsure of their
exact location akasukai crow announces
that shinobu kocho has encountered and
was killed by the upper rank too while
tanjiru holds back tears geu notices
that the crow has a piece of paper on
its neck in the new demon slayer's
headquarters karaya ubiyashiki has
become the new head of the organization
is the only remaining male doing so at
the age of only eight he is supported by
his sisters kunai and kanata despite the
deaths of his parents and two elder
sisters he willingly hasn't grieved them
in order to focus on the mission kunai
and kanata also hold back their emotions
to also aid him
their father with his short life span
was strict racing them quickly into
adults as quickly as he could their
elder sisters hinaka and nichika had
never left their father or mother's side
their mother was also kind but strict in
raising them the three each have one of
yushiro's talismans helping them map out
the infinity castle kara notices the
lacking information they need and
suggests telling the crows to spread as
many eyes as they can kunai decides
muzan hasn't left from his place and
instructs karaya into guiding them north
to face him she mentions the only
demonstrator is currently facing upper
moon demons are kanoa and zenitsu the
latter now facing the new upper rank six
zenetsu and kaigaku face off mocking
zenitsu as puny and weak scoffing at his
status as a sharer since he is only able
to do one form zenitsu retaliates though
by mentioning how happy his former
superior seems as the bottom upper rank
leaving kaigaku stunned at his barbed
comment zenitsu questions him on how he
could have turned into a demon but when
kaigaku tries to answer zenitsu cuts him
off and continues saying why would
someone pose to acquire thunder
breathing become a demon zenitsu angrily
yells that jigoro had committed seppuku
by himself upon hearing what kaigaku had
done and zanitsu gets angered telling
him that someone was actually meant to
assist him at that act but instead he
died in agonizing death all alone all
because a user of their thunder
breathing became a demon kaigaku scoffs
at the news and asks him if he's meant
to be sad or repent unapologetically
refusing to care he declares he will
always stick to those who value him he
states he is glad jigoro died a painful
death angered at all his efforts to
please him never led to him being named
his successor and insults him further by
scoffing at his idea of sharing the
successorship with dirt and calling the
former hashera senile sinister furiously
tells him that if he was dude kaigaku
was garbage since he can only use the
first breath and kaigaku never managed
to learn it at all commenting that
jiu-guru only died a miserable death
because he wasn't lucky enough to have a
true successor kagaku angrily tells
anetsu though not to lump him in with
the likes of himself and unleashes the
thunder-breathing fourth form distant
thunder sending lightning at the demon
slayer however zenitsu had already
avoided the attack and slashed the
demon's neck mocking him telling him
that he is too slow and that he was
filth leaving kaigaku stunned wondering
why his opponent seems like a completely
different person
kagaku then remembers his unfortunate
encounter with the upper rank one
kokoshibo
he comments it isn't shameful to kneel
before an overwhelmingly powerful foe
recalling when he quickly surrendered to
the demon he believes as long as he is
alive he can always do something even if
he has to scrape his head on the ground
drink dirty water or steal to survive in
a flashback we see that kokoshibo offers
a portion of muzan's blood from him if
he wants to become more powerful and if
muzan accepts him he can take a place
among the upper ranks kukoshibo advises
him that it takes time to become a
powerful demon as powerful as a strong
swordsman and at that he gives kaigaku a
large amount of blood since he's also a
breath user he tells kaigaku to be
thankful for the blood he has given but
threatens to behead him should he spill
a drop at that time his whole body was
terrified before his transformation but
now facing zanetsu kagaku's fear is a
non-existent
he's assured no matter how powerful he
is sinitu cannot beat an upper rank
declaring everybody has to die
eventually and saying ji guru and
zinetsu are no exception kagaku uses
thunder breathing second form rice
spirit to kill him zenitsu takes notice
of his five simultaneous attacks
deducing he must have eaten numerous
people already he asks the demon if he
knows right from wrong the kaigaku
responds that those who accept him are
right and those who don't are wrong as
he uses the thunder breathing third form
thunder swarm he then uses thunder
breathing fifth form heat lightning
hitting zenetsu and burning him as he
asks his former swordsman how he likes
his newfound demon enhanced forms kagaku
follows up with more thunder breathing
sixth form rumble and flash hitting him
again with numerous slashes
as zanetsu falls after being hit he
remembers back to his days training
alongside kaigaku ironically zenitsu
only managed to do the first form kagaku
was able to do all of them but the first
of the thunder breathing techniques
zenetsu knew deep down that kagahu was
never going to be a hashera one day
sinitsu had hit a senior demon slayer
and kaigaku reprimanded him then mocked
him for doing so he knew kagaku
virulently hated him zinitsu himself
also hated kagaku greatly but despite
this he genuinely respected kaigaku for
his work ethic and drive and despite his
place especially with geoguru's students
it never satisfied him finally he
considered kaigaku's feelings like a box
of happiness in his heart his happiness
always leaked through and he must always
close that box to feel satisfied
apologizing to jigoro and kaigaku
zenitsu lands on the wall and stops his
fall as a confused kaigaku looks on
sinetsu uses his thunder breathing
seventh form hanokazuchi nokami and
speeds upward decapitating kaigaku in
that moment as the upper ranked demon
becomes enraged that he never saw it
coming he curses his former master for
teaching zenitsu something he never knew
and playing favourites sinister replies
though that jigoro was never such a
person and that he actually created this
form for the day that he would fight
alongside him
after zinetsu beheads kagaku they both
fall in the infinity castle to their
deaths zenetsu plummets unconsciously as
the disintegrating kaigaku grows furious
from his defeat at zenitsu's hands he
comforts himself with the idea that
zenitsu will die with him when they hit
the floor until yushiro comes to save
zinetsu while coldly reminding kaigaku
that without friends he will end with
nothing since he gave nothing to anyone
finally commenting that dying alone sure
is pathetic isinitsu awakens in a land
full of red spider lilies and sees his
master jigoro across a river that
separates the two zinitsu breaks down in
front of him crying in remorse and
regret for not being able to save
kaigaku and being unable to become a
hashera prior to his death as initsu
struggles with being caught by the
lilies he realizes that jigoro hasn't
said anything to him and shikoro breaks
his silence by calling out zenitsu's
name and with tearful eyes he proclaims
is his pride and joy
in reality sinitsu is being parched up
by yushiro while being guarded by morata
and another demon slayer morata realizes
he remembers zinetsu and calls out
hoping for a survival leading yoshiro to
tell him to shut up esmerata angrily
comments back that he cannot be treated
like this as a demon slayer of rank
yushira responds back as a demon he
ignores them as he patches zenitsu's
eyes and morata shouts at the demon that
the blood from zenitsu's wounds
continues to bleed yushiro tells initsu
he was lucky kaigaku was inexperienced
with his demon powers and that if he had
fought him a year later he would have
ended up dead for sure maratha yells not
to be so negative attracting demons to
the location to the other's dismay
yushira was brought along by tamiyo to
help assist the demon slayers much to
his frustration despite the fact he wore
the demon slayer's uniform to enter no
one even recognized him the others
members knew something was off but the
fact that he was a demon created by
tamiyo went unknown shiro grows
frustrated at murata's inability to
behead the attacking demon and places
zinitsu in a safe spot to assist
meanwhile tangido and geyu are
continuing to run throughout the castle
he tells shinobu that they will win and
that he is sure of that suddenly a
powerful trimmer strikes shaking the
area and worrying the two water
breathers
as tanjido wonders if it is a fight or
someone's death the trimmer gets closer
and stronger gear tells tangero to stay
back as the source of the trimmer
punches through the ceiling revealing
the source of the noise to be a kaza
akaza tells the demon slayers long time
no see i'm surprised a weakling like you
is still alive tanjudo kamado causing
tanjido to yell his opponent's name back
elsewhere we see that tamiya is trapped
in a flesh cocoon made by muzan slowly
being absorbed in all the while she
desperately pleads for help while in the
process of mapping out the floor of the
infinity castle kunai begins to envision
the recently deceased members of her
family her emotions begin to overwhelm
her and her eyes well up with tears but
her brother karia reassures her to stay
strong in order to win the battle after
the small delay she recomposes herself
and continues to map out the floor plan
sitting outside of the room are former
hashira tengan and shinjuro standing
guard they begin conversating at how
mature and wise kariah has become
despite losing his father at such a
young age shinjuku mentions how the
youth are risking their lives and how he
had decided to follow his late son
kyogiro and put his life on the line to
protect them elsewhere on the estate
sikonji is seen caring to an illness
he reveals that he had given niziko a
medication that would revert her back to
a human be questioned if it was actually
taking any effect the idea of niziko
returning to a human would ruin muzan's
sheen of trying to conquer the sun and
she would be deemed the only demon in
history not to be destroyed by sunlight
sekonji begins to tremble at the idea of
the conflict ending on that night and
being alive to witness it he reminisces
on the day when he first met tanjido and
how he felt that the beginning of the
end had finally come he quietly begins
to root for tanjudo and niziko begging
them not to lose meanwhile within the
castle tangido has begun to engage ikaza
in a fight whom lunges forward to
forcefully attack first tangier was
narrowly able to escape the blow by
using hanokami kageta wheel to whip over
a kaza now behind him tanjiru wills
himself to slice a kaz's arm off and
successfully manages to do so but is
swiftly attacks when akasa manages to
regenerate his arm to his advantage
tangier narrowly avoids his attack by
using hinokamikagera fake rainbow and
slices akazu across the face in the
process akazu regenerates his cut while
he stares stunned at tanjuro's ability
after having witnessed their small
scuffle gehu stands amazed at tanjido's
techniques thinking of how his ability
is equal to that of a heshera's he
recalls the snow day of when they first
met and how all he could do was big for
his sister's life compared to how we can
now fight without losing his life or
dignity akasi recalls the final word
spoken to him by kiyojiro this boy isn't
weak and do not insult him and
acknowledges tanjido's strength and
informs him of his newfound respect for
him akaza then begins initiating his
technique development to fight tanjido
in a serious manner geu uses
water-breathing third-form flowing dance
to maneuver around a kaza the lesser
recognizing him as the water heshira and
stating it has been 50 years since he
last faced a hashera that uses the water
breathing akasa responds by using
destructive death disorder disrupting
guillo's movement and forcing them to
use the water-breathing 11th form dead
calm to negate the attack the upper moon
mentions the last water hashera he faced
never used such a form tangible appears
from behind using hanokami kagura raging
sun to slash atakaz's neck only for the
blow to miss and for the demon to appear
behind him instead about to punch
through his neck tanjiro nearly gets hit
trying to use the hanukamikage to fake
rainbow to dodge when geru saves him by
slicing off hikaz's arm using water
breathing second form water wheel
kaza's arm grows back nearly instantly
however and geru quickly attacks again
followed by tanjiro using hinukamikage
flame dance akaza sees him trying to
slice his foot and use his leg type
crouch splitter knocking the demon
slayers tangero tries to parry with his
blade and though he nearly comes out
unscathed akazi's leg catches tanjido's
nose slightly causing him to bleed
heavily from the sheer force tangero
crouches down to soak up the pain
leading gehu to face akaze alone
akasa compliments his opponent's sword
and asks for his name only to be denied
as giu tells him that he does not have a
name to tell the demon and that he hates
talking so do not bother the demon
happily responds and will continually
ask him until he gives in using leg type
explosive flurry to hit his blade handle
knocking the hashera away through
several walls tanjunu sees the impact
and calls out to gilu only for akasa to
appear alongside him excited now that he
knows the opponent's name
the two swing at each other and tangible
uses hinokami kagura bernie bone
summersun and akaza deploying his
destructive death eight-layered demon
core and retaliation akasa survives the
clash unscathed while tanjiru is forced
back slamming into the wall akasa
complements his moves and for training
so much in a short period of time he
praises kyogre ringoku for the day of
their battle as tanjuro was a weakling
lying down that night now however he
sees tanjulo's growth in battle and is
now excited to face him akasa voices his
gratitude at kiyojiro's death as he
believes he would have never become
stronger than that day also insulting
his belief to remain human tanjiru hears
these words and remembering kyogiro
shinjuro in sinjiro he becomes enraged
telling him to stop insulting the former
flame heshira akazu is confused
retorting he is praising the two while
tanjuro only tells him he is insulting
kiyojudo as well as hating anyone who
faces him the demon claims tanjudo is at
a misunderstanding as he only hates the
weak as he states that the laws of
nature dictate the weak to be eliminated
the demon slayer responds back that the
upper rank himself is the product of his
wrong views as he himself was once weak
as well and had become powerful tanjuno
yells that they strong protect their
weak then their weak get stronger and
help those weaker than themselves
calling it the true laws of nature he
calls the kaza's beliefs unforgivable
and voices that he will not let him do
as he likes any further facing off
against tanjiro akasa cannot brush aside
this unpleasant feeling he is giving him
he is unsure why he feels angry fighting
him since he believes tanjuro is no
longer weak yet cannot shake the feeling
of his eyes voice and words cutting into
him
at that moment someone grabs a kaz's
shoulder and confirms tanjido's words
everyone starts off weak they get help
from everyone around them but he should
only compare his own progress against
himself not that of others the man tells
him that the only thing important is
becoming stronger than he was yesterday
and soon he can be the one to help
people angered akasa tries to punch
behind him to hit the man but strikes
nothing as a bewildered tangible caesar
kaza punched the air suddenly akasa
angrily mutters tanjudo you really are
extremely unpleasant
akazi uses destructive death crushing
type 10 000 leaves flashing willow and
ruptures the ground around him with
tanjuro just barely dodging the attack
as he becomes stunned at a causes new
speed the demon then quickly engages the
demon slayer from below and uses his
destructive death leg type flying planet
thousand wheels with tanjuno taking the
attack and vomiting as a result he tries
to reason as to how akasa manages to
nearly hit him with every move all his
strikes seem to aim for his vital areas
and his attacks seem to be attracted to
them he thinks back to when the demon
deployed his technique deployment
compass needle but before he can figure
it out tanjulo dodges to the side to
escape an oncoming kick tangero uses the
hinokami kagura solar heat haze but only
manages to cut halfway through ikaz's
neck who manages to heal the cut
instantly however the upper moon is
curious as to how the tip manages to
appear hazy before hitting him asking
the demon slayer how he did it elsewhere
sinjiro prays for his late brother
kyojiro that a major part of the battle
is now active pleading for him to
protect tanjiro and spirits sinchiro
thinks to his written letter to tanjuro
about the conversation between the
sun-breathing swordsman and the flame
hishera of that time and how the
swordsman was the first breather user
and had engaged muzan in battle as
senjudo continues to pray for his
brother and that tanju will survive it
is revealed that the kasuki crow with
his letter is sitting nearby watching
the battle forcing tanjiro to survive
the battle in order to read it as
tanjudo attempts to use his hanokamikage
to fire wheel akaza catches the blade in
his hands startled that he will attempt
to break it tanju instantly headbutts
the demon but doesn't injure a kaza at
all he attempts to kick him but akaza
continues to grasp the sword suddenly
kaz's hands are sliced off freeing
tanjuto and his sword as gear returns
stating that he's angered at the searing
pain in his back and sarcastically
thanking the upper moon for blasting him
through several walls as geyu and akaza
face each other giu comments on the
reason he fights he doesn't want to
battle to the best of his ability and he
doesn't like battles whereas opponents
continually swing for fun but now he had
never faced someone who overwhelmed him
with his first clash guillo states that
akasa's senses are all finely tuned and
polished his own senses are now switched
on to a state where only the strong
battle as he finally understands here
that the moments of life in a battle
truly test someone's abilities tangier
watches as giyu unlocks his demon slayer
mark hugh rushes towards and swings the
blade just messina kaz's neck akasa
tries to punch his head off but the
hashera ducks down and swings again with
the demon bending back to escape the
strike akasi realizes the mark has
appeared and his speed has now increased
geyu uses water-breathing fourth form
striking tide and slices through a
kaza's forearm the latter however had
attacked as well and had struck the side
of ghiyou's head tanju watches the
battle commenting how to spike geyu and
akaza are now virtually as fast as each
other akasa had immediately matched
guillo's newfound power he knows in a
battle of stamina humans will lose and
despite this battle taking place the
final goal is to beat muzan tanjura
tries to think how akash's attacks
managed to be so accurate and how he can
also predict attacks he doesn't see
immediately remembering the moments
akasa mentioned battle spirit in the
battle with kyojiro he attempts to
define it and recalls the conversation
he had with inosuke anoski claims that
battle spirit feels like a stinging
sensation where the enemy is aiming for
tangido believing it to be the reason he
could notice guitar's attacks enosuke is
asked to demonstrate and he asks
tanchiro to look at the part of his body
which he accurately determines as his
right shoulder as tangiero becomes
amazed and oscar notes that when someone
is looking at him with a murderous gaze
it is easier to determine when they will
attack and his whole body will sting if
that set attack really wants to kill him
however he becomes angered that someone
looking at him without the attempt to
kill becomes difficult to notice
remembering how the old lady at the
wisteria house suddenly appeared behind
him without him able to notice it
he then reasons that if he battled a
demon without showing the attempt to
kill it would be easy to kill them
butanjiro believes it impossible to kill
a demon without showing any kind of
intent despite remembering it as a
childish conversation tangero notes
interesting points within it and tries
to use them with the current battle
against the kaza he believes the kaza
does send something in his opponents and
that gives him the edge in combat but
angelo cannot figure out what it is he
tries to think how he can interfere with
a destructive death compass needle he
uses seeing a kaza open from giu's blow
he attempts to use his hinokami kagada
flame dance on the upper moon's exposed
neck but akaza catches the blade without
seeing it as they shock tangero watches
helplessly akasa mocks him for his open
flank and uses his other hand to strike
atanjiro's stomach but only manages to
cut him slightly at that moment tangero
figures out the entire situation
tundra remembers how his father seemed
like a plant he had never shown any
emotional outburst and was always gentle
maintaining his demeanor till his death
whenever he remembers him he immediately
pictures his soft smile and calming
voice tanjuno remembers a question he
asked him about what he thinks when he
performs the hanokami kagura even as a
child tanjiro knew that the dance
involved performing all 12 moves from
night till dawn continuously worried
about his frail body tangido asks if he
can be the one to do it next year
tanjuro thanks his son for his concern
but brushes aside his worry stating that
in his later years performing it he
hasn't felt tired
he remembers learning it from his own
father but notes that even though when
he was younger and healthier then doing
it exhausted him greatly he figured out
though the forms had useless moves what
mattered was using the correct breathing
and movements as well as releasing all
your strength through minimal movement
tanjuro states that by doing this your
mind becomes invisible but to properly
do so here to find his movement and
sensations utilize all his senses and
gain complete awareness of his body he
tells his son that by doing all of this
he can learn to remove unneeded parts of
the hinokami kagura and learn just to do
what is necessary and close off
everything else tanjuru asks how he can
do everything else and his father
responds by saying it's like people
closing their eyes to hear better his
body will adapt and their movements will
become natural tanjuro tells him that
when his mind becomes invisible he will
see into the transparent world but this
is the end as his body would have
reached its absolute limit as an amaze
tanjido asks if he can do it as well he
is told that he can do so by working
hard and not slacking off an incident
happened ten days later before tanjuro's
death a bear had come to the mountain
killing and devouring people as the
kamado family sleeps through a blizzard
tanjuro suddenly awakens and gets up
after which he asks his sleepy eldest
son to accompany him as tanjoro and
tanjiro wander outside the two encounter
the very beer which is standing over two
meters tall and is already believed to
have killed at least six people a
frightened tangible watches his father
confront the bear with only an axe and
his frail body tanjoro apologizes for
its hunger but warns the creature that
coming any closer will mean facing him
he tells her that if anything tries to
harm his family he will show no mercy
and take its life as the bear roars and
lumbers forward to kill him tanjuro
swings his axe and leaps up decapitating
the beer before it could move a step
forward as its giant head drops to the
ground tanjulo tries to piece together
what had just happened in that instant
tanjura would have to swing twice to get
completely through its neck and with his
sense of smell he realizes tanjiru never
wavered in the slightest he had no
hesitation fear no intent to kill with
his plant-like presence he just simply
killed it tanjuro looks behind and asks
if his son had witnessed what happened a
shaykh in tanturo confirms he saw what
took place and runs into hager's father
as he tells his son to never forget what
he saw tangero looks back and realised
that this moment was a form of training
his perception he was supposed to learn
to see into the transparent world just
like his father grandfather and great
grandfather before him they would have
had to learn in this way he finally
understands his father's words and
thinks back to when he managed to
suddenly dodged a kaza strike earlier
that seemed like it was about to connect
though it would have surely killed him
he managed to somehow escape her for
just a slight moment when akaza grabbed
his blade and it was poised to swing
tangier had entered that transparent
world seeing akash's muscles through his
body as he did to hantengu managing to
close off his other senses to dodge
something completely unavoidable his
body became even faster he apologizes to
anosuke for doubting him and tanjido
steals his resolve that while geyu
battles a kaza he will use his newfound
power to his best ability and beat the
demon having seen the transparent world
momentarily tangier realizes his own
movement and speed had increased greatly
he was able to see how akash's body
reacts in battle and concludes he may be
able to behead him if he removes his
battle spirit completely to avoid his
senses akasa begins to overwhelm geyu
the letter having used all of his water
breathing forms only for akaza to
immediately adapt to all of them and
anticipate what one he was about to use
the upper moon decides to finally kill
him commending the hashera for lasting
this long and battle as tanjiro attempts
to enter the selfless state geyu tries
to strike the demon's head directly
akazu responds though then using the
side of his fist to break guillo's
mature and sword without getting harmed
as gu becomes stunned at having his
sword broken akaze fear wells him before
crouching down and going to punch
through his stomach suddenly akash's
hands fall off saving gehu from getting
hurt as tanjulo has managed to enter the
selfless state and bypass a kaza's
compass needle gear looks on at
tanjudo's new appearance and power
akash's body becomes stricken with the
uncertainty at tanjudo's changed aura so
he deploys his final form technique
development blue silver chaotic
afterglow heu looks at this new threat
and is uncertain if he can negate it
with his own dead calm tanjudo however
seen into the transparent world again is
able to detect the attack with his
increased perception and vision
giu is unable to beat akash's new
technique and is knocked back against
the wall with his dead calm being unable
to handle the force the demon commends
him for surviving such a large number of
fatal blows and tells him don't die like
kiyojiro or tanjiro instead become a
demon geyu however the water heshira
becomes confused wondering how akaze can
state that he killed tanjuro watanjiro
standing directly behind him realizing
maybe he is unable to sense his partner
he mutters to tangido to go for the neck
now that akaza is unaware tanjudo calls
out to the upper moon and declares that
he would decapitate him annoying girl
for announcing his attack out loud akasi
retaliates by attempting to swipe the
demon slayer's head only for tanjiro to
duck down to safety suddenly he notices
he cannot sense anything seeing tanjuro
is completely different from before with
his battle spirit seemingly gone akasa
tries to calm himself and believes that
he will be able to sense an attack but
without warning his head is sliced
completely off by tanchiro who was using
the hanokamikaketa
sun transformation with geyu stunned at
angelo's sun improvement akasa declares
that this is impossible despite being
beheaded by tanjiro akasa internally
reflects on the battle spirit of people
he had never encountered someone who
could remove theirs commenting that
fighting tangier felt like fighting a
plant despite his senses and compass not
working properly on the battlefield
anything unexpected can happen he
notices tanchito managing to surpass his
own speed in a short amount of time but
his eyes showing no intent to kill ikaza
believes tajiro has achieved the
selfless state he so badly wanted to
attain himself something he believes
that he should have done so by now the
upper rank tries to put his head back on
top of his neck with the resolve to
continue fighting however geev flings
his broken sword at his head knocking it
away from his grasp the upper rank
repeats his drive to continue to get
stronger as his head starts to
disintegrate tanjuro becomes relieved
but immediately stiffens up due to his
body hitting his limits however upon
seeing akash's body not disintegrating
geyu and tanjudo worriedly look on
akaza's headless body activates
destructive death compass needle again
and immediately attempts to hit
tangiero's neck though he barely misses
the demon changes stance and hits
tanjudo square on the side knocking him
away tangier realises akazu is trying to
make his head a weak spot no longer
similar to muzan earlier he tries to get
up but faints due to his body reaching
its absolute limit giu sees akasa going
for his unconscious comrade and uses
water breathing fourth form striking ty
to stop him though the cut instantly
heals giu then declares that if akaza
wanted to kill tanjuro he would have to
go through him first and takes his
stance to fight once again akasa sees
his indomitable spirit one that does not
bend in the face of any obstacle
suddenly he sees the same man from
earlier who comments that we wield the
sword in our hearts the things we use
are our fists calling the man an eyesore
akasa moves forward to engage geyu but
is internally held back by the vision of
a young woman wishing hakugi-san to just
stop already
as geyu readies to fight at kaza once
more he realizes the severity of this
situation his body has reached its
limits his senses are failing his body
is numb and the only thing keeping him
up is his breathing calling it a miracle
for him to continue battling despite the
heavy toll on his own
gear now focuses on protecting the
unconscious tangido resolving to never
let friends or family die on his watch
again knowing tanjuro would do the same
the woman's spirit grabs a casa telling
him to not go
akasa tells her to go away asking who
she is and she tearfully begs for them
to go to the other side but he only
responds to her that he must kill
tanjiro and giu when asked why akasa's
only answer is that he must get stronger
but when she asks why he needs to get
stronger he answers because if i don't i
won't be able to bring the medicine back
for dad as zakaz's memories come
flashing back to him we dive into a
flashback whereakaza was once known as
hakuji an 11 year old boy who stole
money and food to keep his father alive
one fateful day he was caught beaten and
given tattoos to mark him as a thief the
villager's magistrate warns the boy his
hands would be removed the next time he
steals only for him to say that he can
go and cut them off as he still has his
feet and will steal with those instead
the magistrate tells him the beatings he
received would cause a strong man to
become numb calling him a demon child
for being able to handle it the boy
continues on telling him to call him by
that name saying that he was born with
fangs after his beatings and threats by
the authorities hakuji walked home until
a man informed him of terrible news his
father had heard he was caught and had
hung himself in shame while hikuji was
in the cemetery he read the final letter
that his father had written out before
his death his father wrote to him
tehekuji please live an honest life so
that you can turn over a new lead i
don't want to live off money that has
been stolen from others and i'm sorry
for being a nuisance
after reading the letter and finding his
headstone hakuji tearfully grabs it and
grieves his death he asks how his father
can make peace with such people finally
cursing the world and telling it that
everyone can just go to hell hikuji
recalls his b teens for stealing money
and how he could endure anything for his
father no matter how severe he wonders
why he had hung himself declaring he
would have died for him
after being expelled from ido due to his
rage he was left to wander the streets
eventually making his way to a village
where he found seven men and almost beat
them to death leaving them their
unconscious all while saying his father
never hurt anyone he didn't bother him
and he didn't need to apologize
afterwards a martial artist came by
drawn by the news a boy was about to be
killed instead finding that said boy had
actually beaten the seven men barehanded
amazed at this feat the man cheerfully
asks if he would like to be a student
only for the still hurt hikuji to
threaten him back later on the man takes
the awakening herkuji for a tour of his
dojo and he introduces himself as kaizo
a master who teaches the bare-fisted
martial art called soryu style however
he didn't have a single student so he
made his living off handyman work
kaizo asks the boy to care for his sick
daughter a task his recent wife used to
do but had killed herself over due to
its exhausting nature hikuji asks why he
would leave his daughter with a criminal
only for keizo to cheerfully remind him
that he beat up that said criminal
kaizo's happy demeanor reminds akaza of
why he hates tanjiro so much because
tanjida reminds him of kaizo a figment
of his boring and worthless past as he
continues to call his past worthless he
reaches the memory of where he first met
kaiyuki
kiyouki's sick appearance reminding him
of his own fathers
as kaizo goes away to work he leaves the
two together kyuki asks if he has heard
seen his injured face akash curses his
human life remembering the promises he
made and failed to deliver he declared
his life worthless filled with empty
promises
hikuji asks himself why sick people are
always apologizing remembering the times
his father did so and kayuki now
apologizing that he can't train while
caring for her kuki was born with a weak
body and had to be attended to day and
night however hakuji was fine with the
task as he had previously cared for his
ill-father and his resilient nature
meant that he never tired he never felt
like playing around anyway and simply
trained in his free time hikuji mentions
there would be fireworks on display and
that he was willing to carry her to the
bridge to watch with him when kiyuki
seems unsure he reminds her of next year
and the year after there she begins to
cry somewhat annoying him that she would
burst into tears mid-conversation he
believes she cries due to the depressing
nature of her illness while commenting
her crying made him feel uncomfortable
while kaiser and akuji share a drink at
the well the master mentions how their
names are actually similarly structured
to be based on a phrase meaning protect
therefore they must protect something a
fact that makes keizo laugh keizer
recalls how the dojo came to be he says
he had protected an old man with the
suryo style of combat and that man
amazed at the feat had given him the
land and place for the dojo later on
however the nearby kinjutsu dojo found
out and began to harass the sorry dojo
which led to him having no students this
was mitigated in keizo's eyes by
training her kuji and caring for kayuki
something that he said healed his heart
years later hakuji turns 18 and kyuki
turned 16. in that time kyuki had gotten
better and no longer needed to
continually lie down she was also now
happy and bright
while cleaning the floors hikuchi was
summoned to the dojo and spoke with
kaizo where he told him that he wanted
to take over the dojo and casually
mentions how he can also have his
daughter kiuki as well a statement which
ends up shocking the both of them hikuji
never believed he could have a future as
a criminal much less a future as a
husband with a wife he remembers his
father's letter to him and recalls the
swelling feeling his life could go
anywhere declaring now that he wants
more than nothing to protect kaiyuki and
kaizo even at the cost of his own life
hakuji travels back home to tell his
father's grave about his marriage but as
he returned to the dojo he suddenly
began to breathe heavily and a sinking
feeling came over him there someone
informed him the well they drank from
was poisoned by the kinjutsu dojo
killing kaizo and koyuki seeing their
bloodied lifeless bodies on the dojo
floor hikuchi laments that he's never
there to protect his loved ones in a
crisis he suddenly remembers a moment
back when kyouki came with him to watch
the village's new year fireworks while
there kyuki asked about the conversation
they had about the fireworks while they
were younger something that he had
forgotten but something that she had
never forgot
when he was unable to watch them that
year he suggested the next one to her or
the year after that and she recalls when
she didn't believe in herself living
another year or so on hugh remembers
when her mother killed herself being
unable to care for her any longer and
believed in a way her father was tired
of caring for her as well she saw hakuji
casually asking if she was willing to
see them next year giving you hope of a
future kuki asks if he would like to be
her husband and hikuji graciously
answers so yes i will become stronger
than anyone else and protect you for my
entire life in the end though akasa
laments that it was just simply words
and he couldn't manage anything in his
life filled with rage and losing the
people he loved once again hikuji went
to the kinjutsu dojo and brutally killed
or 67 members inside using this suryu
style he eviscerated their bodies the
dojo was found with crushed skulls
destroyed organs brain limbs and
eyeballs strewn throughout the building
all the corpses destroyed to the point
they were unrecognizable as a human body
the incident was so horrific and absurd
that it was regarded as a fictional
story before being erased from history
in the wake of the destruction a blooded
and broken hikuchi encounters muzan
kibitsuji
muzan had heard about the carnage and
mistakenly thought that he had sent a
demon to do so instead finding that a
mere human had actually done it leaving
him somewhat disappointed hikuchi
threatened to kill him when the demon
lord suddenly rushed forward and pierced
his head with his hand before he could
fight back
muzan comments he was thinking about
building a group of 12 powerful demons
and asked tsukuji if he could withstand
the amount of blood that he was about to
be given hikuchi declares to him that he
no longer cares about anything anymore
and transformed into the demon a kaza
then and there
akasi recalls losing his human memories
in the wake of turning into a demon but
continued to have the drive to get
stronger and stronger though in reality
he had nothing left to protect in the
end akaza comments that his life was
nothing more than a pathetic comical
uninteresting story azakazil laments he
cannot go to heaven like his father
kaizo and kiyuki he becomes furious that
tanjuro and geyu have reminded him of
his painful past he curses humans as
weak soft brittle they die right away
and disappear into nothing
suddenly tanjido awakens from his ordeal
shocked at how he fainted mid-battle as
zakaza begins to regenerate his head he
begins to deploy his annihilation type
as tanjiru yells at him to stop the
demon becomes shocked that tanchiro has
managed to survive his kirk declaring he
will behead akazia again tanjuro's sword
ignites with the fire of the hinokami
kagura however his sword slips out of
his grasp forcing tanchiro to punch
kaz's face instead the punch reminds him
of when he first met kaizo making him
remember why he hates weak people weak
people never fight face to face they
poison wells they are impatient he
killed these weak people with his fists
and he suddenly realizes throughout his
life as a demon he turned his master's
fighting style into a bloody weapon and
never respected his father's last words
finally realizing who he must truly kill
as tangible panics about his lost sword
and seeing a kaza about to use the same
technique that killed rengoku he
suddenly notices geyu in the attack
range though geu tells him not to worry
about him tanjiru grabs him and throws
both themselves out of the technique's
path suddenly he sees a kaza smiling
slightly followed by an immense
explosion the attack leaves the
surroundings devastated as well as
akaz's body now a broken bloody mess
wondering why akasa would attack himself
tangier smells a scent of gratitude
coming from the corpse as well as asking
himself why he had smiled before
self-determinating the body begins to
regenerate but akasa stops the process
telling himself that the fight is over
he had lost fear and square he comments
that tanjiru had magnificent technique
anticipating and slashing before he
could react the broken body begins to
walk away while akash's spirit comments
he would go to hell as a man
when he stops to tangies confusion his
spirit mates with his fathers asking if
he was alright his father comments yes
calling him hikuji and thanking him as
he bows and crouches down apologizing
for being unable to fix himself his head
is held by kaizo's spirit kaizo tells
him that they would never abandon him no
matter what despite akaza not being able
to go to heaven with them as he calls
out for his master muzan appears grabs
his head and scolds him reminding him
that he had to get stronger and continue
fighting with that his body starts to
regenerate again even quicker akaza
voices his will to keep his promise and
get stronger declaring once again that
he will kill everyone suddenly though
kaiyuki touches his face thanking hikuji
and saying that he has done enough
though muzan appears again calling him a
kaza once more
he overcomes muzan's control and grabs
kogi's spirit on the verge of tears as
once again the human hakuji he carefully
apologizes for being unable to protect
her for not being there when she needed
him for not being able to keep his
promise
while he cries for forgiveness kyuki is
glad that hikuji had remembered them all
despite his long demon life and
returning as a human again
with his words welcome back my husband
akasa stops his regeneration and tangier
watches as his body finally fades into
ash
hikuchi calls out to his father kaizo
and kyuki that he is back home his
spirit becomes engulfed in the fires of
hell joined by kyuuki tanjuro watches as
akaza's body finally fades into nothing
declaring that the battle is finally
over
realising that he must reach tamiya to
help her his body can no longer handle
the fatigue and he falls on his face
unconscious
surprised that tanjuno had suddenly
fainted geyu tries to call out to him
but faints from exhaustion as well rest
in his body on his sword a kasugai crow
calls out the aftermath of the battle
tangero and geu have managed to defeat
the upper moon 3 but are now unconscious
elsewhere we see that kokoshibo no
longer feels akash's presence and
realises he has been defeated as a kaza
has lost the upper moon won comments
that he could have never been able to
beat him remembering his threat earlier
at his life as he voices that akasa had
opened up the path to reach further
heights and abandoned it he grabs his
own sword and furiously slashes the
pillars of his room cursing a kaza as
weak
over in the cult room doma hears the
news of akasa's demise and comments that
he felt like a kaza had turned into a
different being before he had died as he
brushes aside his comment he asks kanoa
for her name
she introduces herself as kanua adding
that she is the little sister of kane
and shinobu kocho burma is confused
judging that she doesn't appear to be
blood related to the two but nonetheless
comments that the young girls are
delicious either way
while on the subject of eating woman
derma mentions the subordinates
conscious decision to not eat woman
owing that fact to his demise despite
mentioning that women have more
nutritional content to demons than men
akazu refused and was even given special
permission by muzan to do so since akaza
was only deployed by muzan on special
missions
as he mourns for his best friend's death
kanoa tells him to stop the lies she
figures out easily durma does not even
feel the least but saddened as the color
on his face has stayed the exact same
when doma responded back it's due to him
being a demon though kanoa retorts by
mentioning that demons and humans both
circulate blood and the colour of their
faces can change she mentions that kane
had felt sorry for him as he feels
nothing she talks about how all people
are born with the ability to feel
happiness as well as sadness and anger
doma cannot understand these feelings
but knowing he was intelligent kanoa
instead tears into how he covers up his
lack of feelings with a facade of lies
pretending to experience emotion to hide
the fact his heart feels nothing he
feels no happiness no bitterness no pain
calling him an empty shell and saying
his facade is so comical it's stupid
finally she mockingly asks why were you
even born
doma comments that throughout his life
he has talked with numerous young women
but never a bully like kano and asks how
could she say something so cruel kano
retaliates by saying it's because of her
outright hatred of him her desire to
completely cut off his head she changes
her opinion of him and tells him that
he's not very smart calling him a
disgrace and smiling as she mentions it
was better to kill him as his life is
utterly pointless and meaningless
therma instantly appears behind her
trying to slice her neck boccano reacts
in time however and crouches down to
slash through his abdomen when he tries
to send out ice dolls to hit her she
dodges the incoming attack to safety as
doma heals he comments that her reaction
speed has accelerated and she is
adjusting to his own movement also she
has not inhaled any of his ice despite
it being an extremely difficult task to
attack in her mana without using a
breathing technique doma suddenly
realizes that kano might actually be
more powerful than shinobu
kano feels that the goosebumps
throughout her body aren't stopping she
even knows to put strength into her
fingertips to hold your sword or risk it
shaking she mentions the demons she had
faced in the past pale in comparison to
doma but she is able to face him due to
the immense anger she feels anger so
powerful it feels like her body is
literally burning she feels she must
rampage at him or her body would rip
itself apart the dizziness in her head
and her anger turning into hatred she
calls out that she hates doma and asks
how he could kill her entire family kano
vanishes and instantly appears before
him using flower breathing fifth form
peonies of futility to rapidly slash him
doma comments that the consecutive
attacks are pretty and retaliates with
his blood demon art baron hanging garden
kano attacks back with the
flower-breathing second form honorable
snow plum to destroy the ice created
doma notices the key to withstanding his
attacks are her eyes she notices his
movements and predicts his next actions
in anticipation complimenting her as
smart and above the average swordsman
the demon decides the best course of
action is to gouge out her eyes doma
slashes at her face but kano bends back
in time only sustaining a small cut to
the left side of her temple using flower
breathing sixth form whirling peach she
attacks back at the upper moon who
compliments her body and her flexibility
saying that it is extremely well trained
doma deploys his fearsome freezing
clouds forcing kanua to close her eyes
or risk freezing them while on the
defensive she is attacked again by doma
using blood demon art lotus fines the
ice vines converging on her and forcing
kano to slice the incoming attack to
defend against them when she is finished
cutting them apart germa quickly attacks
with his blood demon art cold white
princesses kano again backs away to
avoid the fog but must dodge again when
doma unleashes another blood demon art
wintry icicles from above and nearly
impales her doma taunts her for getting
away from him mentioning that in order
to kill him she needs to actually get up
close he disappears for a moment and
reappears clutching her maturing blade
despite kano aware and anticipating his
next moves doma mocks her for not
holding onto the sword and sticks it
into the bridge near him he tells the
demon slayer to come and get it and
deploys his blood demon art scattering
lotuses in her direction kanoa forces
herself to look through the incoming
hail of ice to find the area of minimum
damage but sustains multiple cuts to her
face still
suddenly anoski smashes through the roof
announcing out of the blue that the lord
himself enosuke is coming through and
using beast breathing fifth fang crazy
cutting he destroys the incoming wave of
ice shards saving kano he thanks the
kasugai crow for leading him to the
right room inosuke looks intently at
durma's eyes and enthusiastically
realizes he is the upper moon too he
declares he will defeat him and finally
become a hashera
a confused doma mentions that he isn't
hiding his identity as upper moon too
anosuke sees the injured kano and warns
her that she noble will get angry at
seeing her condition but when kano
doesn't respond and she becomes upset
anosuke is completely stunned into
silence doma overhears him and mentions
that shinobu will live forever inside
him as that's how everyone i eat gets
saved inosuke is left completely shocked
as he remembers the memory he had where
shinobu pinkie promised him to not
remove the bandage of his injured hand
anosuke angrily declares on noor at your
shreds trash and charges towards doma
despite kano warning him not to inhale
the cold air he creates using beast
breathing fourth form slice and dice
anosuke slashes that doma at the same
time the demon comments on his messed up
technique as well as noticing his
chipped blades in unorthodox fighting
style when doma attempts to slash in
anosuke's neck he flips back and
deflects the fan with his feet earning a
compliment from the upper moon for his
flexibility and intrigued by his mask
anoski lands next to kano and presents
her with her blade stolen from the
unaware doma to her shock doma comments
that the demon slayer is fast and grows
more ice to attack only for enosuke to
deflect them back and kick him in his
stomach knocking him away anosuke
charges forward and readies a slash
derma comments that the attack is far
from the sword's range so when the
boar-headed figure swings he becomes
completely and utterly shocked that the
attack had managed to reach him and
slashed him across his eyes and nosquay
had used his beast breathing ninth form
extending bendy slash dislocating the
joints of his arms to extend his range
he relocates the bones of his arm but is
angered at the new attack's inaccuracy
made him miss doma's head tikano's
complete shock doma is left amused at
his unusual opponent and comments that
throughout his own life he had never met
a fighter like him anoski takes the
compliment and says that it's because
the other riff-raff are losers and
nothing compared to him but while
enosuke is talking his mask instantly
appears off his face surprising him and
shocking kano doma in that moment had
stolen it without either demon slayer
noticing and comments that the boerskin
is quite old as inosuke angrily demands
his ball mask back doma suddenly
responds that he knows he has seen in
oscar's face somewhere before doma asks
if he and enosuke had met any past
causing inosuke to get angry and retort
at his statement demanding him to hand
his mask back however doma is sure that
they have and he knows him from
somewhere enosuke responds again that he
has not met doma before but doma
mentions the only one he encountered
before was shinobu leading in oscar to
comment that he felt as if he had met
who before when kano attempts to leading
oscar away saying doma is spouting
random nonsense doma becomes surprised
and offended stating his only saving
grace is his seriousness and long and
clear memory even during his human years
with that germa pierces his own skull
with his finger takano and inosuke shock
and disgust doma fiddles with the inside
of his brain until he reaches a
particular memory and retells it to the
two fifteen years ago there was a young
woman with a baby roughly 17 to 18 years
of age she was abused by her husband and
mother-in-law daily and encountered
doma's paradise faith cold she had no
siblings or parents and had no place
else to go when doma first met her her
face was severely swollen from the bee
teens commenting that it was pretty
rough even to him the woman was even
partially blind but when he touched the
woman's face her face went back to
normal she was so beautiful it left an
everlasting impression on the even
apathetic doma he mentions she had the
same face as in oscar and concludes that
it must have been his mother inosuke
says that he has no mother and was
raised by bores to which doma replies
that you're a human so a human must have
given birth to you but inosuke charges
forward without listening and readies is
beast breathing sixth fang takano's
concern only for doma to state this
encounter is a miracle and
simultaneously slashes adinosuke's chest
twice creating an x-like mark he quickly
summons more ice and knocks both demon
slayers into the cult room's pond as
kano urges inosuke to calm down doma
continues his story he says that he had
no intention of eating the woman as
having someone as beautiful as her next
to you felt pretty good though he
considered her unintelligent she was
talented at singing the woman
continually saying a pinky promised
lullaby to her baby doma mentioning that
she's saying with different lyrics each
time and adding that this song soon
became a village song inosuke realizes
that the pinky promise song was not
because of shinobu doma says that he
purely planned on letting her live her
life but learn that though she wasn't
particularly smart the woman named
kotaha was sharp she soon learned that
doma devoured the followers of the cult
and ended up confronting him for his
lives and fleeing the temple kotaha
apologizes to inosuke cursing herself
for continually making mistakes even
going the wrong way after she left the
temple all the while she repeatedly kept
saying that she was sorry she became
lost in the forest and unable to find
the village cornered at a cliff's edge
she apologizes once more to winosuke
before dropping him off the cliff into
the water doma kills her shortly after
this
he believed the baby would have
definitely died from the drop of the
cliff and cried at how sad the situation
had become anoski suddenly figures out
that she was killed and that doma had
eaten her to the very bone and noted if
she went to her husband he would have
continued to beat her and if she was
alone by herself on the road she would
have ended up dead as well
doma mocks kodah's life for being so
unfortunate asking if there was ever a
happy moment in it and cause your
existence pointless kano furiously tells
him to shut up though as inosuke grabs
his fallen swords from the water he
remembers his mother's love for him
durma comments that it was truly a
miracle meeting ninosuke here which
fills him with more rage as he declares
that the demon who killed his mother and
his friends is standing right before his
eyes he stands back up and thanks doma
for letting him remember everything but
voices that the demon won't cut off his
head now he takes a stance and readies
to fight doma declaring that he is going
to show him what hell is truly like
doma tells enosuke that though he was
raised by boars and knows his way with
words he is still mistaken the demon
claims that heaven and hell don't exist
and that they are figments of human
fantasies to him the humans who live
righteously suffer tragedies while the
evil live free to do whatever they want
adding that since divine punishment
doesn't exist mentally weak people
therefore believe the evil go to hell
upon their deaths he tells them that
they keep this belief deep in their
minds and calls humans pitiful and oscar
screams out that he decides then that
he'll instead create a hell for doma as
he charges telling doma to stop talking
about his mother's life as unfortunate
doma retaliates with his blood demon art
freezing cloud and an oscar uses his
tenth fang whirling fangs rotating his
blades to disperse the icy cloud kano
attempts to attack doma from behind but
he anticipates her swiping his fans at
her neck though she parries the fan his
swipe still knocks her into the water
doma clings to the roof causing enosuke
to yell for him to come down and face
him doma tells them that ikaza is
defeated and he no longer has the time
instead creating ice stalls to fight the
demon slayers as they land ignoski and
kanoa are confused but are soon shocked
when the dolls use scattering lotuses to
fight them doma tells them the eye
stalls are as powerful as him leaving
him to it as he leaves making inosuke
furious kano tells him to focus on their
battle as a doll uses frozen lotuses to
slash arunosuke forcing him back doma
notices ignosuke isn't breathing in his
fog confusing him as the dolls use cold
white princesses and envelop the room
with more fog anosuke becomes incensed
that everything around him is freezing
durma is intrigued by him as a fighter
that he had never faced before he
decided to force the demon slayers to
use all their techniques as the
information would be useful to him in
the future as kano is forced to hold
back another lotus vine onslaught she
hopes shin ninosuke can keep doma inside
the room with them for a little while
longer however doma immediately decides
to create a fifth doll to kill the
combatants quicker or face getting
scolded with that he forges one in his
fans and releases her the doll
immediately deploying wintry icicles to
not karna with further back
soon inosuke's arms get slashed by the
icy vines worrying kano as she tells him
to hold out for just a while longer she
herself becomes overwhelmed by the
continuous slashes of ice lotuses doma
overhears her and is confused at how
they will survive for any longer knowing
his dolls will record anything during
the battle he decides to leave but as
doma opens up the door of the occult
room his face suddenly begins to melt
confusing him to kana was gratitude he
collapses to the floor and suddenly
thinks back to shinobu from earlier in
the past when shinobu and kano had
confirmed about if they ever encountered
the upper moon too shinobu believes if
she encountered him and kano happened to
fight alongside her she would need to be
eaten first shocking her younger sister
kano pleased that she and her would
fight the demon together only for
shinobu to respond back to abandon those
thoughts she tells her that she knows an
upper moon is as strong as at least
three hashiro minimum and according to
their late sister kane the upper moon ii
is gluttonous with an obsession for
eating woman shinobu knows if the demon
faces a heshera with great abilities a
body in excellent condition and as a
woman he would definitely eat her
worrying kano further she tells kano
that her body is currently concentrated
with wisteria poison
as kano tells her she is also willing to
go through the exact same thing shinobu
tells her that it is impossible to reach
the level that she is at as she has been
absorbing the poison for over a year now
shinobu confesses that she was the first
to do such a feat herself unsure of the
potential side effects in the future and
unsure if her plan would work on the
upper moon or even muzan she states her
sword has 50 milliliters of poison but
whatever demon consumes her would also
consume 37 kilograms worth of poison in
her body weight derma collapses further
from the effects of shinobi's poison his
arm falling off his bones beginning to
melt and his regeneration failing
he realizes he never felt the poison
circulate through him until now
his eye stalls soon fracture and
collapse as well to enosuke's confusion
kano realizes shinobi's poison is
working and they now have doma cornered
shinobu tells kanua that she doesn't
even know if her life's worth of
expertise on poison would even work on
an upper moon demon kagaya ubishiki
himself had deemed it impossible but
advises her to consult with a certain
demon for further knowledge shinobu
tells her sister if the poisoning did
start working she must never let her
guard down adding that the only way to
kill the upper moon is by severing his
neck she knows she will definitely
weaken him but she tells kanu to deal
the finishing blow
back in the reality of the fight kanoa
becomes assured she will kill the upper
moon too and resolves to not let
shinobu's life go to waste as shannon
converge on doma he summons his final
technique blood demon art remain water
lily bodhistiva with the two stunned at
his new threat the giant ice figure
slams down onto the colt's pond signing
inosuke and kano flying back kano
realizes if they get forced away from
the fog dermal will have the time to
recover and if they entered the fog and
inhaled it they would no longer be able
to fight however she notices though that
doma's body sliver is powerful it is
still shoddy doma has lost all of his
precision and creating it was a
last-ditch effort she decides to use her
own last technique and remembers her
last moments with shinobu shinobi warns
her that using the technique might blind
her eyeballs are delicate with very thin
blood vessels and nerves telling her to
not endanger and burden herself by
releasing such a powerful technique
bakana rejects her warning asking why
should she worry about her vision when
shinobu gave her own life she calls her
sister sweet and an honorable person
declaring that she wanted to protect her
life with her life and she wanted her
aoi kio sumi and naho and herself to all
go home together kano activates flower
breathing final form equinental
vermilion eye causing her eyes to flush
full of blood and her perception
heightened to an even further level the
giant bodhistiva becomes slow in her
eyes she realizes her protective coating
that wraps around most of her eyeballs
are turning red and in that moment
quickly slices up the ice figure's hands
to reach doma as she swings at doma's
decaying head the bodhistiva turns back
and blasts kano with icy fog freezing
her back and arms her sword reaches his
neck but she can no longer swing further
with her arms stuck frozen inosuke
saying this and having been recently
saved by kano uses his new technique
sudden throwing strike hurling his
blades at doma his swords connect with
kanos gripping into them and driving her
blade through doma's neck decapitating
him in that moment
domer expresses his disbelief at having
his head sliced off he expresses his
self-pity for losing to a sword builder
who didn't have enough strength to slice
off necks even though he had put much
effort into what he believed was for
other people's sakes however he doesn't
give up right away and thinks to himself
that he still has a chance and might not
die like muzan he also knows akaza was
also able to start growing back his head
however as doma's head falls to the
floor and bounces his body begins to
disintegrate and he realizes that he is
truly going to die he thinks to himself
how he doesn't feel anything recalling
back to his childhood his mother had
stabbed his father to death and the
latter had flirted with numerous female
followers later committing suicide via
poison shortly after despite this
tragedy his only thoughts were about
ventilating the room he couldn't
comprehend the deaths because of his
apathy and was only bothered by the
smell of their blood doma remembers how
he was turned into a demon at the age of
20 and lived for over a century but in
the end human emotions had been alien to
him
in the afterlife shinobu holds doma's
head in her right hand the former
expressing relief at doma's death will
they smile she states that she can now
be at rest derma greets her asking
whether her name was shinobu or kane
shinobu smiles and tells him that he
doesn't have to remember their names
asking him not to address them because
it was creepy durma compliments shinobu
about the intensity of the poison
claiming he didn't even notice the
poison until it had fully circulated
through his body shinobu explains that
tamiya had assisted her in making the
poison expressing her slight frustration
that if she could she would have wanted
to kill doma with her poison she had
made herself suddenly doma claims that
his missing heart feels like it is
beating asking shinobu whether this was
love expressing his surprise that
emotions did indeed exist he then goes
on to think that heaven and hell may
exist as well asking shinobu whether she
wanted to go to hell with him to this
the letter tells him to just go to hell
already as she is completely and utterly
sick of him meanwhile inosuki stomps on
the place where doma's disintegrating
head once was yelling insults growing
dizzy he then falls to the ground he
recalls the conversation he had with
tanjiru and zanetsu inosuke had been
yelling that he didn't have a mother but
tanjuro tells him that everyone has a
mother to wachinoski responded that he
was abandoned which meant that his
mother did not want him zenitsu replies
that ifanosuke had truly been abandoned
his mother wouldn't have bothered to
name him anosuke retorts back that he
doesn't have memories of his mother
which was the same as not having one at
all but tanjiro gently reminds him not
to speak of his mother that way stating
that his mother must have loved him a
lot
suddenly inosuke begins to cry as he
remembers his mother kano on the other
hand looks for shinobu's hair clip
noting her inability to see clearly from
her right eye
she realizes her own hair clip formerly
kane's is now broken to her sadness kano
apologizes to her sister and recalls the
time when kane had died she was unable
to cry at that moment bothering her
greatly kano had been making excuses
inside of her heart and clutches at her
chest but when she feels the apparitions
of shinobu and kane softly passing her
on the head and telling her that she did
well kane looks up to only find that
they weren't there elsewhere in the
dream world shinobi reunites with her
sister and her parents and the pond
holding both her adoptive sister's
headpins kano begins to cry as tangido
sleeps he smells something burning he
tries to sleep further but he realizes
that it is a fire quickly jolting awake
he sees geyu putting his sword through a
small fire he builds when asked by
tanjiru gyu states his wounds haven't
stopped bleeding despite putting
pressure on them resulting in him
burning them to tanjuro's disgust geyu
extended the offer to tangido noting if
the bleeding in his arm didn't halt he
can burn them as well to which tangier
worriedly agrees tangero stands upright
and holds his sword out to be on guard
but you state that this fight is only
the beginning the final goal is muzan
but he is worried they may soon face
upper moon 2 or even 1. at that moment
akasugai crow announces that shinobu
kano and inosuke had defeated upper moon
2 to the shock of both of the water
breathers tangero then realises that all
of the slayers are slowly getting closer
to muzan meanwhile matsuri had found
nakime now the upper moon four obernai
realises the previous one defeated by
machiero and company had now been
replaced matsuri laments that shinobu
risked her own life to win despite being
younger than her giving her the
motivation to attack nakime head on the
demon summons a door however slamming
matsuri away to her embarrassment obinna
catches her though and takes her to an
upper platform to safety only for the
floors to be opened by nakime causing
both of them to nearly fall
they regroup however nakimi retaliates
by causing the flaws matsuri is standing
on to rocket to the ceiling resulting in
her nearly getting crushed till she
destroys the floor she is on the
lovershire claims that she won't fall
for that trick earlier nearly hitting
nakeme who subsequently opens another
door causing an annoyed matsuri to fall
through obanai uses snake breathing
second form venom fangs of the narrow
head but misses when nakime summons a
building to block his path to this he
comments that though nakime's blood
demon art isn't deadly it's by far the
most annoying and troublesome elsewhere
gyome and muchiro continue through the
castle sensing muzan is close suddenly a
wall compartment pushes muchero
separating the two he is forced through
multiple walls before landing in a room
full of numerous pillars inside the room
the demon notices him and comments he
looks rather familiar material is
shocked as it reveals that he is now
face to face with the upper moon one the
upper moon one kokushibo examines
muchero to kiso in the transparent world
and recognizes something in the boy as
mature looks on adam thinking that the
upper rank 1 is quite dignified and
majestic mature notices the blade at the
demon side and wonders if he had been a
demon slayer in the past suddenly
mature's hands start shaking with a
sword handle and its grip unable to
shake the feeling of tread from being in
front of kokushibo with his body
refusing to battle something that had
never happened before in his entire life
majira attempts to compose himself
kukushibo asks him what his name was and
material tells him with kokushiba
responding that the tsukikoni name has
died out puzzled mature asks him husuki
gurney is and kokushibo continues saying
that it was inevitable after so many
centuries the upper ring tells muchero
that when he had been human his name was
michikatsu tsukiguni and then reveals
that muchiro is his descendant mature's
eyes widen with shock and he refuses to
believe it at first with his mind
swimming with questions about the upper
rank coming back to earth quickly mature
steals himself and prepares to attack
with koko shibo praising his mental
strength lording him for overcoming his
panic in such a short period of time as
mature swoops forward and attacks him
with a missed breathing second form
eight-layered mist that the demon
effortlessly dodges in the blink of an
eye appearing behind muchiro kukushibo
praises the boy's breathing technique
seeing that his descendant was a missed
breathing user and then swiftly dodges a
missed breathing fifth form sea of
clouds and haze launched by the mr
shearer accurately deducing muchiro's
age as being 14 kokushibo is impressed
that the boy's swordsmanship is so
refined at his young age and his mental
fortitude to quell his fear and battle
the demon taking pride in the strength
still flowing from those of his blood
displeased mature rebuffs the upper rank
saying that if a hundred years have
indeed passed then not a drop of
kokushibo's blood remains in him mature
then activates his demon slayer mark and
performs a misbreathing seventh form
obscuring clouds a technique that
kokushibo had never seen before as
muchero slices at the demon's neck
fukushibo quickly evades the attack
impressed with the beauty and grace of
the technique drawing his own blade
kokoshibo performs moon breathing first
form dark moon evening palace that
muchero is unable to keep up with and
the hashera sadly loses his left hand as
a result shocked that the upper rank is
able to use breathing techniques as a
demon mutura quickly attempts to
restrict the bleeding from the stump on
his arm by tightening the sleeves of his
robe with his teeth he then dashes
forward and attacks kokoshibo despite
his injuries and the demon is impressed
at the courage and the skill of his
descendant as the mr shira performs a
missed breathing fourth form shifting
flow and slash kokoshibo catches the
boy's blade between his fingers and
turns it on him pinning him to a pillar
and then he asks muchiro to allow him to
turn the hashera into a demon so that he
could serve muzan kibitsuji kukushibo
stands in front of mochiro after having
pinned him to a pillar with his own
blade and says that his heart is moved
on seeing one of his own descendants
something he had never imagined machero
stares at the upper rank in silence as
kukushibo continues and says that the mr
shira's arm would regrow once he became
a demon certain that muzan would allow
such a thing given that the other upper
ranks had all been slain transfixed on
his descendant kokoshibo attempts to try
and stem muchuro's bleeding but then
says that if machero died due to excess
blood loss or if he was rejected by
muzan then it would be fate kukushibo
tells maturo that this would mean that
he was a man and only meant to go so far
in the background sneakily genya
shinozugawa attempts to sneak up on the
demon as he shoots at him he is left
utterly shocked as kokushibo instantly
appears behind him and asks if he agrees
with his statement slicing off genya's
gun arm so fast that he wasn't even able
to notice as guinea's left arm falls to
the ground the boy looks in shock and
attempts to defend himself as matero is
horrified and yells out to kenya before
his hand is able to fully draw his blade
kokoshibo swiftly slices off his other
arm as well leaving the boy bleeding
profusely he sees that kenya has been
eating demons and slices his torso clean
in half
mature was horrified at the sight and
attempts to pull the blade out of
himself but in vain as he is unable to
make it budge kukushibo is surprised
that genya is still alive despite having
his torso cut in half and tells him that
around 300 years ago there was another
swordsman who ate demons just like he
did saying that he had killed a
particular swordsman by slicing his
torso in half kukushima says that if the
same strategy did not work on kenya then
perhaps the boy's weak point was
actually his head kenya tries to crawl
towards his arms to attempt to reattach
them as kukushima says that he has no
reason to allow a fake demon like him to
live and begins to slice at his head
suddenly he is intercepted by sunimi
shinozugawa performing the wind
breathing fourth form rising dust storm
as genya is left shocked kogoshibo
immediately retreats backwards and
recognizes sunimi as the wind hishera as
the later says that he is the wind that
will rip off kokushibo's head kenya
whispers to his brother who roughly
responds by calling genya a pathetic
little brother telling him that the
reason he went so far as to kill their
own mother was that he wanted to protect
kenya flashing back to a conversation he
had with tangido during his hashira
training kenya remembers that tangier
told him he could not smell a tinge of
hatred and tsunimi towards genya and
tanjudo had told him that he did not
need to be afraid of his brother because
sanemi had loved him that entire time
sanemi continues and tells kenya that he
should have lived a normal life until he
reaped a ripe old age and attempted to
make his wife and children happy in
return for all the happiness that had
been taken from them their siblings and
their mother assanimi tells him that he
would have not let a single demon get
near genya no matter what genya tears up
and apologizes to his brother meanwhile
kukushibo feels nostalgic upon seeing a
pair of demon slayer brothers enraged
though sunimi curses at kokushibo and
lunges forward to attack as kokoshibo
slices at him ducking and sliding
between kokoshibo's legs tsunemi catches
the demon's foot and flips him over
launching a wind-breathing first form
dust whirlwind cutter at the upper rank
without pause tsunami matches blades
with kokoshibo who finally draws his
sword out for all to see a grotesque
blade with eyes and veins running down
the side of its length and senemy notes
how disgusting the sight of it truly is
tsunemi and kokushibo go blade to blade
and the upper moon unleashes a moon
breathing fifth floor moon spirit
calamitous eddy that the wind hashera
manages to dodge noting that kokushibo
is able to repeat his slashes without
even moving his blade sunimi prepares to
counter-attack dashing forward sanemi
performs a wind-breathing third form
clean storm wintry and clashes with
kokoshibo but is unable to damage the
upper rank impressed kokoshibo lords
sinimi's physical capabilities and knows
that they are at their peak as the
hashira is silently awestruck at the
demon's own prowess analyzing
kokushibo's attacks and seeing that each
slash is accompanied with smaller
crescent-shaped blades that change their
size randomly over time sunimi thinks to
himself that he is not surprised muchero
lost to this demon thinking that if it
was not for his inexperience he would
surely have been able to cut him down by
now tsunami gets excited at kokoshibo's
skill and the fact that he is a demon
using breaths seeing that this makes him
a much tougher opponent sunimi is
thrilled and calls kokoshibo a demon
worth killing launching a wind-breathing
second form claws purifying wind sunimi
leaps forward as kokushibo deflects
anemi's attack he looks up and sees the
wind teshira about to slice down at him
and blocks the blow suddenly tsunemi
goes straight for kokoshiba's neck with
genye's sword maneuvering the blade with
his right foot kenya looks on and shock
at this move as the upper moon narrowly
evades the two continue to battle with
sunimi matching kokushibo blow for blow
much to the demon's delight the intense
combat begins to take its toll on sunimi
however as the wind hashera finally
slips up and narrowly messes up the tip
of his swing missing death by a small
margin kenya looks on with his eyes
widening in concern and mature calls out
to sunimi who is frustrated but alright
kokoshibo reminisces over old battles
and thinks back to a fight he had with a
previous windhashera back in this in
goku era and how both of them had
improved their swordsmanship by fighting
in a similar manner suddenly launching a
moon breathing sixth form perpetual
night lonely moon kokoshibo manages to
slice sanemi's chest and even cuts off
all of the surrounding pillars in the
room with his attack kenya calls out to
his brother frustrated as the rubble
blocks his view leaving him unable to
see his brother with blood spilling from
his chest sanemi stands up straight and
finds slashes running alongside his
torso kokoshibo praises the enemy's
skill for having kept up with him for so
long but tells him that if he moves now
his organs would spill out suddenly he
tenses up as his pulse begins to race
and he is puzzled at the sun change
cinema begins to cuckle as he sees that
the effect of his rear blood even began
to work on an upper rank with a smirk he
lashes forward and attacks kokoshibo
taunting the demon for staggering as he
glows that his rare blood made demons go
drunk off the smell of it as he begins
to counter attack in earnest the
windhashera recounts how he first
learned about the special quality of his
blood and thinks back to the night his
mother became a demon he noted that her
movements had become duller after his
blood had spilled and surmised that she
had gotten drunk off the smell of it
afterwards he began to hunt demons all
on his own being unaware of the demon
slayer core or nichiren swords instead
he relied on his own blood to
disorientate the demons enough for him
to restrain them and then quickly burn
them in the sun the nights were
difficult for him as he had become
partially blind after killing his mother
afterwards he realized that this had
been a reckless endeavor that he tried
doing and he had been incredibly lucky
to actually have gotten through it
unscathed one day while hunting for a
demon cinema ran into a demon slayer
named masachika kumano who was also
hunting the same demon this is where
sunimi learned the actual existence of
the demon slayer corps and would join
them afterwards they became friends and
even fought and defeated lower rank 1
while working together however masachika
was fatally wounded in the fight against
the lower rank and ended up dying
leaving tsunimi the only one to become a
hashera as a result of their win back in
the fight against kokoshibo tsunemi
unleashes a wind-breathing sixth form
black wind mountain mist which the upper
rank narrowly dodges shocked to see
saneemie being capable of fighting
kukushibo guesses that the hashera is
squeezing his muscles to prevent his
organs from spilling out and solidifying
his blood with his breaths to stem his
bleeding impressed at the hashera's
immense skill kuroshibo note that this
is a feat no ordinary human could
achieve and begins trading blows with
sunimi the windhashera keeps pushing
kukushibo back but the demon suddenly
stomps down on his blade preventing him
from moving it and then attempts to
behead sunimi flashing back to when he
first became a hashera still raw from
his sadness over the death of masachika
sanemi recalls his ashirami teen when
they had first laid eyes on kagaya
ubishiki sunimi had boiled with rage at
seeing someone who was smiling while
there were people who were suffering at
the hands of demons hurling verbal abuse
at oyokata and saying he only saw the
demon slayers as pawns sunimi had
immediately earned the ire of his fellow
hashera with his disrespect kyomei had
reapproached him but assured the hashera
it was all right before things could
escalate further and then addressed
sanemi directly kagai told him that he
had wished to fight with their blade
himself as well but was never able to do
more than ten swings before his pulse
went wild and he would have to stop he
continued and said that if the demon
slayers were pawns then he was nothing
more than a porn who moved them around
as well kagaya continued his response to
sunimi's words and told the winter shera
that even if he died nothing would
change as he already had successes
oyokata said that since this was
sanemi's first ashira meeting and that
he probably just had a misunderstanding
to treat him however he wished and had
just focused on protecting people's
lives as a hashera kagaya continued and
said that it was his fault for calling
sunimi so soon after masachika had died
as they had been as close as brothers
sunimi was dumbfounded to hear this and
that oyakata knew masachika's actual
name
after this kanekoto told him that kagaya
had actually memorized all of the names
of every single demon slayer and the
upbringings ever since he had taken over
as the leader having been shocked to
hear so sunimi had looked in ore as
kagaya had gotten up and informed them
of massachusetts will
saying that the will of most demon
slayers would be similar kakaya had
handed over komino's will to sunimi and
the boy tearfully read it and it told
him that the demon slayers would always
want their loved ones to live with their
smile and to not die unnatural deaths at
the hands of demons remember in these
moments senemy pulls out a pistol and
blocks kokoshibo's blade with the
underside of her before firing straight
at the demon's face kukushibo defiantly
blocks the bullets with his blade and
then unleashes a moon breathing third
form lonesome moon chains enemy vanishes
from the range of the attack and
kukushibo exasperately says that the
demon slayers just keep on coming as he
sees gyome standing in front of him as
the stoneheshira declares that the demon
slayers have permanent until every last
demon slayer is exterminated from the
world gyome tells anemi to stitch up his
stomach wound and that he would distract
the demon to allow him to do so salemi
agrees to this and apologizes for
getting into such a state to begin with
as the stonehishera steps in to fight
the upper rank the demon notes with
excitement that gyome has refined his
body to its utmost limits saying that he
hadn't seen a warrior with this strength
in 300 years germain continues swinging
his flail and inhaling deeply the whole
time while kokoshibo notes that the air
is being drawn towards him finally
attacking kokoshibo with his weapon
jeremy looks on as the upper rank dodges
his attack but he quickly throws his axe
at the demon as well kokoshibo who had
been about to attack gyomay is forced to
abandon this idea and evade the axe as
well he attempts to attack again but
gyome unleashes a stone breathing second
form upper smash as kukushibo evades
this attack guroma catches him in his
chains restrained kokoshibo attempts to
break free but isn't capable of damaging
gyome's chains the stone hashira
attempts to cut off kokoshibo's head
with his axe but the demon dodges only
losing a lock of hair that is severed
kukushibo is enraged and charges at
gyome attempting to slice off his neck
but the heshira jumps out of the way at
the last second filling in his axe at
the upper rank but only managing to tear
off some of his robe continuing his
assault gyome swings his flail
ekokushibo as the demon evades yet again
however gurmen manages to catch
kokushibo's blade between his chains and
pulls on them shattering the blade and
the two face off with a stone breathing
fourth form volcanic rock rapid conquest
and a moon breathing second form pearl
flowers moon gazing as kokushibo's blade
finally recovers from the blow it
received he taunts gyome by saying that
no matter what damage he receives it
will all recover
in response jeremy utilizes a technique
he had been saving up for the battle
with muzan kibitsuji finally revealing
his demon slayer mark inosuke and kano
run through the infinity castle not
knowing that just around the corner from
them azinitsu and morata back at the
battle against kokoshibo maturo
struggles to dislodge himself from where
he had been pinned by the upper rank
slowly dragging the blade out of his
body with his remaining hand mature
manages to extract his blade and kneels
over in pain once seen he steams his
bleeding and assesses the situation
noting that he would not be of much use
with his current injuries and that he
would take some time to be able to stop
his bleeding as he had not been blessed
with the same physique as someone like
tengen uzui determined to do something
no matter the cost though mature
resolves to do his best to defeat
kokoshibo and aid those who are still
fighting as he grabs his blade and
begins to run over to the fight material
is distracted by genya calling out to
him to get some of the hair that had
been cut off from kokushibo so that he
could eat it and recover as he wanted to
fight till the end to be able to help
his brother sunimi
meanwhile kukushibo and gyome face off
the demon notices gyome's demon slayer
mark and says it is a pity noting that
gyumei looked to be at least 27 years of
age he then revealed that all those who
had gotten demonstra marx had died
before they had become 25. predicting
that gyome would die that same night
kukushibo says that everything gyome had
worked for up to this point would all go
to waste and asks kiyome if he does not
find that regrettable silently enraged
at these words jeremy tells kukushibo
that he and the other demon slayers had
been aware of this story about those
with marks or dying before reaching 25
asking what there was to regret about
his life at their points guyme declares
that no one could become a hashera with
such a half-hearted resolution and
declares that kokoshibo's words are
insults to him kokoshibo attempts to
explain his views more by saying that he
meant the techniques and body gyome had
worked to hone over the years and
wonders why gourmet could not understand
this the stonehishira responds that
there is nothing to understand and that
humans understood their dignity was best
preserved by living and dying just as
human beings he rebukes kokoshibo
further and tells him to not force his
pathetic worldview on others and call it
the supreme one continuing on gyome says
that he had noticed kogoshibo had lied
when saying no one with a demon slayer
mark had lived past 25. kokoshibo
attempts to deny this though but is cut
off by gyomei saying that there must
have been one exception and kokoshibo
suddenly jolts with an understanding and
remembrance satisfied by this reaction
germa deduces that his theory was
correct just as kukushibo darts forward
towards the stone hashera to slice at
him but gyome is able to block as the
two trade blows sunimi recovers from his
wounds after having been stitched up
having also acquired a demonstrator mark
he wastes no time in attacking kokoshibo
in tandem with gyome and the demon
thinks that all the heshira of the
current time are marked with the
demonstra marks as the two ashira
continue attacking in sync the demon is
surprised at their skilled coordination
while the both of them say that they are
grateful for the fact that they train
together in the hashera training to
allow such coordination mutura checks up
on genya and feeds him a fistful of hair
from kukushibo which instantly heals his
wounds as he begins to become more aware
of his surroundings ginyu marvels at
this new speed of recovery and remembers
that he still has a fragment of
kokoshibo's blade he can eat to gain
further strength and is comforted by
this knowledge suddenly muzan
kibitsuji's voice echoes through genya's
head as he asks kokushibo how many
pillars he has defeated before ordering
him to not let any of them pass kenya is
further impressed at the concentration
of the blood that kukushibo possesses as
the latter continues to battle with
gyome and tsunimi kokoshibo knows that
the pair of them must be among the
stronger fighters and is especially
impressed by gyomei he sees that guyme's
weapons allow him to overcome his
blindness by swinging the chains it
creates an echo that allows gyome to
judge the distance and his surroundings
by only using sound kokoshibo declares
that his best course of action would be
to shatter sanemi's blade by striking it
from the side and attempts to do exactly
that however sunimi is able to react and
rotate his blade he also forces
kokoshiba's blade down onto the ground
before launching an attack right at him
in tandem with gyomei the upper rank is
impressed as sanemi slices off more
locks of his hair and that his reflexes
have actually improved since he was
first wounded by the demon fiome cuts in
close and lops off kokushibo's left ear
with his axe before sanemi performs a
wind breathing first form dust whirlwind
cutter that the upper rank is able to
dodge working together giome and sunimi
unleashed stone breathing first form
serpentinite bipolar and wind breathing
seventh form gale sudden gusts
respectively however it is revealed that
they are only able to rip kukushibo's
kimono and the demon rips it off
entirely before proceeding to attack the
two pillars from afar they left shocked
by this new range and see that his sword
has extended and more blades have
suddenly branched out from it kukushibo
declares that if he is able to defeat
gyomay and sunimi then defeating
everyone else will be quite easy
suddenly shinozugawa is hit by
kokushibo's attack and loses the index
and middle fingers of his right hand
cursing his inability to react to the
demon's strike tsunemi knows that if it
were not for gyomi using his chain to
divert the trajectory of the attack he
would have lost both of his arms he also
sees that the smell of his rear blood
was beginning to lose its effect on
kokushibo realizing that he may quickly
become a burden a crow flies overhead
and koenig ubyashiki asks karai if they
should send over either geyou or tanjido
to assist the demon slayers in defeating
upper rank 1 however kariya is firm in
his beliefs that kyomei and sunimi
muchero and genya could defeat the demon
and orders for geyu and tangido to
continue onwards to muzan back in the
battle kokoshibo unleashes a moon
breathing seventh floor mirror of
misfortune moonlit that sends shock
waves at the demon slayers from afar
jeremy has taken a back at the range of
the attack and kokoshibo continues to
hammer away at the hashera this time
with a moon breathing eighth floor moon
dragon ring tail that catches sunimi's
ankle and causes bleeding sunimi is
frustrated at his inability to get in
close to the demon's head having to use
all of his skill to just simply dodge
his attacks as the demon lines up
another attack he performs a moon
breathing ninth form whining moon swarfs
kokoshibo causes yet more damage to
sunimi slashing his back with the attack
guyama yells out to sunimi but the
winter shira says to forget about him as
kokoshibo attempts to finish him off
with a moon breathing tenth form
drilling slashes moon through bamboo
leaves but muchiro saves sanimi he says
that he would not let saneemie die that
he was capable of wielding his blade
with both of his hands meanwhile kenya
looks on from behind a pillar frozen in
fear that he would simply be
effortlessly dispatched by kokushibo
again hasting his weakness but still
determined to keep his brother alive and
help his friends kenya stays rooted to
one spot neither making their move to
attack kokoshibo nor retreating he
suddenly remembers tanjudo's words that
it was the weakest who had the most
potential when he explained how he had
been able to turn the tide against daki
and gutardo he told kenya that after a
certain number of combatants people
would always prioritize the strongest
and thus their guard would be thinner
against the perceived weaker opponents
resolving to do his best kenya takes out
a shard of kokoshibo's blade ready to
swallow it and do his best to defeat the
upper ranked demon gourmet attempts to
perform stone breathing fifth form arcs
of justice akokushibo but is interrupted
by the letters moon breathing 16th four
moonbow half moon the stone hashira is
frustrated at the upper rank's
never-ending wave of techniques and
senses that the demon is too quick
picking him off exactly as he tries to
fire a technique at him pondering over
what it could be that the demon is
seeing pyoma attempts to focus and
refine his senses saying that demons are
mere transfigurations of the human form
and anything they could do a human could
manage as well saying that his eyes
could see human nature here may declares
that he would not be misled kukushibo
unleashes another attack for a split
second giome to his own shock is able to
see through him and discern his poles
over with muchero though he attempts to
getting close to kukushibo and slow him
down so that he can create an opening
for gyomay or sunimi to cut off the
demon's head jeremy notices this and
coordinates with sunimi to match
matero's run and distract kokoshibo from
three sides adjusting to mature's plan
on the fly kokoshibo sees this as an
opportunity to defeat all three of them
at once and unleashes a moon breathing
14th form catastrophe 10-man crescent
moon at all the hasheras all three
managed to dodge his attacks however and
guyome flings a juzu bead right into the
back of kokushibo's right hand shocking
the demon just enough to hold his
attacks and allow the hasheras to launch
their counter-offensive tsunemi attacks
kokoshibo forcing him back and kyomek
cleaves off the demon's right shoulder
along with his right arm and muchiro
finishes off this trifecta of attacks by
stabbing kokoshibo clean through the
abdomen done kokoshibo wonders how
machero had been able to dodge all of
his attacks while he was wounded
deducing that this would only be
possible if the child was also capable
of entering the transparent world
kokoshibo acknowledges that gyoma had
also been able to achieve such a state
in the middle of their fight and had
also taken his own eyes into account by
manipulating his blood flow to throw off
kokoshibo's attacks undeterred since the
demon slayers had been unable to sever
its neck despite their clever maneuver
kokoshibo plans on analyzing their
attacks to develop a counter-attack and
render them demoralized gioma and
tsunemi charge at him and kokoshibo
prepares to unleash another 16th form as
genya looking demonic steps out from
behind a shera and aims his transformed
gun at the other rank he remembers
mature's advice to not hesitate and says
to himself that as long as he is able to
slow down the demon he is willing to go
down with him
kenya fires his gun but kokoshibo
quickly diverts his attack to block the
bullets however genius bullets rebound
off kokoshibo's blade but swerved back
to attack him on their own shocked at
this kokoshibo looks up at genya and
sees that the boy and his gun have
transformed looking way more demonic
than before suddenly a large tree goes
out of the bullets out of the back of
kokushibo routing him to the ground
seeing that these are blood demon art
kukushibo declares that kenya absorbed
the locks of his hair and broken bits of
his sword to acquire demon powers his
attention is diverted quickly as gyoma
and tsunami lunge at him this causes him
to get anxious and fearful and he thinks
back to the last time that he had felt
so threatened that had been almost 400
years ago back when he had faced his
younger brother yoruichi tsugikuni it
had been the night of a blood moon and
kokoshibo had encountered his younger
brother who should have been more than
80 years of age at the time this was
incredibly shocking to kakushibo as he
thought those with the demon slayer
marks did not live beyond the age of 25
yeruichi had begun to cry at the sight
of his brother and told him that it was
heart-wrenching seeing his normally
reserved and quiet brother showing some
emotion had left kokoshibo bewelded
however this lasted for only an instant
as when yoroichi grabbed his blade he
let off such an aura that kukushibo was
left stunned and afraid
as he charged yoroichi was so quick he
left a slice through his brother's neck
before he could even react
seeing that his brother had lost none of
his strength kokoshibo had been enraged
and his old feelings of jealousy and
hatred began to well up inside of him
once more kokoshibo wanted to kill
yorichi but knew that he would die with
yodoichi's next attack
as even muzad kebitsuji had been pushed
to the brink when he faced yodichi's
skill however that next attack never
came as yet she died resting on his
blade but still standing on his feet
kokushibo lets out a howl and emits
crescent-shaped shockwaves from his body
they slice it all of the demon slayers
the demon suddenly grows blades from his
body and the demon slayers are all
pushed back with genya being vertically
sliced in half though mature stubbornly
hangs on to his blade still piercing
kokoshibo's torso kyomei and sunimi
charge it kokushibo and maturo decides
that he needs to do something to kill
kokushibo so that the other pillars
would be able to save as much of this
drink for the fight against muzan
machido's grip on his blade tightens and
it suddenly starts to turn it red much
to both his and kokushibo shock the
demon suddenly stiffens up in agony as
the bright red blade sears his very
cells taking advantage of the demon's
newfound immobility sanemi slices at his
neck and genya activates a blood demon
art from afar at the flesh bullets still
inside kokoshibo and makes a tree grow
out of his back kokushibo attempts to
swipe at genya but finds that he is
unable to activate his technique and
kyomei swipes at his head with his flail
kokushibo resists having his neck
cleaved off and kyomi swipes at it from
below with his axe the kokushibo is able
to keep it at bay with his blade somehow
nothing that he is unable to activate
his own blood demon art due to the tree
using up so much of his own blood to
grow itself kokoshibo looks at machu's
blade again and is reminded of
yudowichi's blade thinking back to a
conversation he had with his brother in
the past in that conversation kokoshibo
had asked his brother what his plans of
succession was as he believed there was
no one powerful enough to match them and
worried that their perfect breath
techniques would fade from the world one
day but yoruichi had responded to this
by saying that they were not as big of a
deal as he was making them out to be and
that there would come a day where there
were those who would surpass them he
continued and said that they could reach
the end of their days feeling nothing
but ease meanwhile sanemi had jumped and
swung his blade down on gyome's flail to
force it down and chop off kokoshibo's
neck suddenly both the weapons turned
bright red at these spots where they
made contact with each other and they
finally mustered up enough strength to
chop off kokushibo's neck and snap his
blade in two as this happens the demon
could only remember his brother's words
of how their children born after them
would surpass them and reach even
further heights
thinking back to the time he spoke with
youichi about his confidence that their
generation would be the golden age of
the demonstrator corp kokoshibo
remembers how he had been disgusted at
his brother's response he wonders what
had been so funny at the future ahead of
them that there would be demon slayers
who could surpass them kokoshibo
acknowledges the strength and the talent
of those who had been fighting him
noting how they had not let go of their
blades despite their severe injuries and
the capabilities of using blood demon
arse despite being only human continuing
on in spite of blood loss and even
managing to turn their blades red though
they were not sun breathing users asking
what had been so funny about being able
to predict such a future as this
kokoshibo says that the mere thought of
losing made him seethe with anger
resolving not to lose he manages to stem
the bleeding from the stump of his neck
much to the shock of gyome who tells
sunimi to keep attacking the demon to
finally end him and not let the
sacrifices of ginya and muchero to be in
vain
sunimi is fired up at those words and
unleashes the wind-breathing eighth form
primary gale slash at kokushibo as gyome
follows it up with a stone-breathing
fifth form arcs of justice the upper
rank manages to dodge guillermo's axe
and slices off mucher's sword hand he
attempts to pull out the boy's blade and
also remove the stump ginya summon on
him kokoshibo's head slowly begins to
regenerate as he continues to evade
strikes from both gyome and sunimi much
to their shock he manages to fully
regrow a new head but is far more
monstrous than what he had looked like
before determined the hashera continue
their onslaught to defeat the upper rank
and as sunimi charges adam kukoshibo
sees the reflection of his new face and
tsunemi's blade
shocked and disgusted at the ugliness of
his new form the demon remembers the
words of his brother from their
childhood where he resolved to become
the strongest samurai in the country
after his own brother reflecting on
these memories kokoshibo wonders if this
is the form of a samurai and if it is
truly what he had wanted suddenly the
spot near his stomach we hear being
stabbed by muchero begins to crumble
away on its own in this split second
that follows this kokoshibo is
completely and utterly shocked but gyome
and tsunimi managed to cleave off his
new head leaving him completely unable
to use his blood demon art still
unwilling to lose though kokoshibo
attempts to muster up more strength but
suddenly remembers the words of his
brother from their final fights
kukoshibo questions his motives and
wonders if all of this is what he had
wanted from his life and deeds calling
himself a disgrace to life and
acknowledges that all he ever wanted to
do was be like his brother yeruichi
kukushiba remembers his past with his
brother and says that those who do not
envy others are merely lucky as they
have not encountered someone who was so
strong and vivid that they scorched
everything as if they were the son he
thinks back to when they were born and
says that during their time they were
considered unlucky as twins caused
succession disputes yarouichi had been
born with a mark on his forehead which
was considered hideous and he thinks his
father had ordered for him to be killed
however upon hearing this news their
mother had been enraged at him so it was
decided that yeruichi would be sent off
to a temple when he became 10 years old
instead the brothers were kept separated
and kohushibo then michikatsu would
often see yoruichi clinging to their
mother's side and he had found his
brother to be pitiful and childish
machikatsu would sneak to yarichi's room
when their father wasn't looking and
even made him a flute people had
believed yurichi was death as he had
never spoken a word until the age of
seven one day while practicing sword
swings in the garden majikatsu was
chilled to the bone noticing yolichi
staring at him silently from next to a
tree suddenly yeruichi spoke and asked
him if his dream was to become the
strongest samurai in the country
machikatsu was so shocked he dropped his
wooden sword and yoruichi burst into a
smile and said that he would become the
second strongest samurai however
michikatsu was merely disgusted at his
brother's lack of awareness saying that
a kid who ran with his mother every time
he saw her could never become a samurai
yeruichi began to hang around
michikartsi's sword practices and asked
to be taught their way as well
sumitsukatsu's trainer gave him a small
shenai with basic instructions on how to
hold the sword and a form stance the
trainer asked yoruchi to charge him
tomoshikatsu's shock
she was able to shatter the trainer's
wooden sword flip him over and knock him
out unconscious and only four swift
strikes the trainer even grew swellings
the size of fists in these spots where
yurichi had struck him yodichi lost his
desire to become a samurai as he
disliked the feeling of hitting someone
and felt horrible for it machikatsu was
greatly intrigued at his brother's
strength and tried to learn his secret
after much coaxing yerichi said that
their opponent's lungs expanded so they
just had to closely watch their bone
movement muscle contraction and blood
flow machikatsu had difficulty following
this but was able to summarize that his
brother could see through living things
he felt jealous that his brother had
such an immaculate talent to fight with
but absolutely no desire to fight as
yoruichi told him that he would rather
just fly a kite with his brother later
on mochikatsu realized that his position
with the odoichi would become reversed
and he would be the one to live in the
temple instead however that night
uduichi came to him and told him that
their mother had passed away and that he
would be running away from their home
for good saying that he would always
cherish the flu his brother had made for
him before running off
the next day michikatsu read their
mother's diary and saw written in it
that yoroichi had realised that he would
become the ear which is why he had
decided to leave the house earlier than
planned he also learned that yeruichi
was aware of their mother's illness and
that she had been suffering pains in her
left side for several years machikatsu
made the connection between her illness
and yodewichi's constant clinging to her
mother's left side whenever he saw her
and realised that his brother had in
fact been supporting their mother the
entire time crushing the page as he lost
control of his jealousy thinking back to
his past with yeruichi kokoshiba
remembers how he had begged for
yudowichi to die as the justice of the
world went amiss with his very existence
their father had sent invoice to the
temple yada which he was supposed to be
at in the hopes of making his younger
son his ear but found that he had never
arrived there and so michikatsu had
inherited everything for a decade
afterwards he lived in peace even
getting married and having a child
however one day his military encampment
had been attacked by demons who sorted
all his troops and were about to do him
in as well
until a timely intervention from no one
other than yoruichi the moment he laid
eyes on his brother again michikatz's
tranquil days came to an end as he saw
how much stronger iroichi had become and
his jealousy and anger was only stoked
by the letter's good natured apology for
not being able to save her subordinates
possessed by his jealousy machikatsu
abandoned his family and joined the
demon slayer court he saw that yoruichi
had begun to teach the demon slayers how
to use sun breathing and sore techniques
none were able to reach his level and
perform them however he had to work
around this limitation instead focusing
on the strengths of each individual and
teaching them a breath style suited for
them more people began to grow marks
like yoruichi had and the power of the
demon slayers increased and even
michikatsu himself greenmark which was
the same as your cheese michikatsu was
also unable to use sun breathing and had
to resort to using a derivative which he
named moon breathing anguished by the
fact that he was unable to catch up to
his brother soon the mark demon slayers
began dying in numbers as they learned
that they marked shortened their
lifespans in exchange for getting
stronger which signaled that the golden
age of demon slayers would soon come to
an end and that he himself had little
time left remaining actually as well
it was with these thoughts in his head
that michikatu came face to face with
muzan kibitsuji who offered to turn him
into a demon saying that with his nigh
immortality michikatsu would be able to
perfect his techniques as much as he
pleased michikatsu accepted the offer
and felt as if he had been freed from
all of his obligations this was fleeting
however as when he once again faced his
brother kokushibo was utterly outclassed
and he saw with his own eyes that his
brother had transcended the world even
muzan had been unable to lay as much as
a scratch on him and yoruichi had died
undefeated in his old age out of sheer
hate and once again coming up short
against his brother kokushibo swiped at
yerucci's standing corpse with his blade
slicing it into several parts however
there was one final surprise in store
for him and he saw that a bag fell out
of yoruichi's robes the one that
contained the flute he had made for him
when they were children
seeing that his brother had still
cherished their memories together
kokoshibo tears up but is also
frustrated at his brother's continued
excellence kakoshibo says that he had
been unable to forget yoroichi's face
throughout his entire life despite
wishing desperately that he would he
said that yoruichi had been like the son
and that people around him yearned for
him and to be like him but their only
option had been to fail and vanish away
recognizing that he hadn't been able to
obtain anything having abandoned
everything he had to emulate his brother
and had even been unable to wipe out his
breath staff despite killing all those
who knew its forms alongside muzan
kukushibo finally disintegrates away as
he wonders why he had even been born
asking yeruichi this question as he
finally faded away kukushibo
disintegrates away but tsanimi
shinozugawa continues to blindly charge
adam ankyomay has to stop the winter
sheera telling him that the fight is
over he is shocked to see that sanemi is
in fact unconscious and had been
attacking the upper rank in that actual
state
genya still alive looks on at this scene
and weakly whispers gyome's name and the
stoneheshira walks up to check on him
and is shocked that the boy is still
somehow alive he deduces that it must be
due to absorbing a demon and kenya tells
him to focus on treating mochiro instead
kyomei lays tsunami next to kenya who is
relieved to see that his brother is
still alive the stone hashira heads over
to muchiro who lies lifeless on the
ground staring straight above the stone
hishera closes his eyes and says that
maturo had been valiant until the very
end and said that they owed their
victory to the efforts of both mochiro
and genya hyome closes muchero's eyes
shut and says that they would continue
onwards to defeat muzan
opens his eyes in the afterlife and
finds his brother yuchiro tokito
standing in front of him with tears in
his eyes angrily telling him to go back
he begins to well up in materia's eyes
as he is hurt that his brother still
does not praise him for all his efforts
and asks why his brother is still bent
on rejecting him yuchero responds by
asking why he worked so hard instead of
running away and mature says that it was
because he could not abandon his friends
but yuchiro is adamant and calls his
brother's death a pointless one asking
if even knew why he was born a mature
retorts that his brother had died when
he was 11 and was more pitiful than
himself going on to say that he was born
to be happy mature tells his brother how
he had sad and painful moments ever
since they had been left alone by the
deaths of their family but despite that
he had managed to smile again this was
down to all the friends he had made and
all the times he had shared with them
matura says that he has no regrets he
hadn't run away from anything and even
laid his life down for his friends and
asks his brother not to call his death a
pointless one as coming from him those
words hurt more than they would
otherwise uchira apologizes for his
words and hugs his brother
meanwhile tsunemi comes in and sees
genya disintegrating before his eyes
horrified he screams out shocking gyome
as kenya apologizes for being a burden
and thanks him for protecting him cinema
says that he hadn't protected him at all
as he is dying right now despite all of
his efforts but ginyu responds that his
brother had tried his hardest and that
he had done enough kenya says that he
wants sunimi to be happy as he knew his
brother was the sweetest person in the
entire world tsunemi cries as kenya
fully disintegrates and kyomei walks up
behind him to remind him that it wasn't
fully over until they defeat musa and
kibatsuji
as word spreads of the deaths of muchero
tokito and ginyu shinozugawa tanjiro
begins to cry quickly attempting to
compose himself though he thinks of how
everyone else had to keep their feelings
in check and fought till the very end
thinking back to the letter he received
from senjuro which had revealed to him
that there were in fact 13 forms of the
hanukkaami kagura one more than the
twelve forms he currently knew resolving
to do his best to defeat muzan
regardless tanjudo continues to run
forward with geyu meanwhile coria
realizes that they would be unable to
make it to where muzan was in time and
tamiya wouldn't be able to hold off the
demon for much longer as he learns that
the first group of demons have reached
muzan's location with the second troop
also close he immediately issues an
order for the demon slurs to stand by
and not approach muzan saying that they
should further wait for the hashera to
arrive
as the first troop stands in front of
the capsule of flesh muzan is locked in
along with tamiyo they see that they are
unable to reach it as it is suspended
over a steep fall into the depths of the
infinity castle being suspended in a
place by outgrowths of flesh from the
capsule one of the demons says suggests
that they should slice at the
outcroppings of flesh he is interrupted
however by muzan bursting out of the
capsule where they jump the demon kills
the entire first troop in mere seconds
as karai reiterates his orders for the
troop to maintain its distance as they
would only serve as food for muzan to
recover the crow's cries are wasted
however as the entire troop has already
been killed by muzan and he also strikes
at the crow beheading it in one stroke
he says that when one lives for a
thousand years they lose the feeling of
enjoying the taste of their food but now
that he was hungry he found the taste of
his victims to be incredibly delicious
he thanks kagaya ubiyashiki for
unwittingly preparing this feast for him
and says that he was unaware of which of
his children led the demon say a core
now but they were quite superb thinking
that he might turn the new oyakata into
a demon to replace his now dead
subordinates if they bow before him a
mouth on the palm of muzan's hand
finishes 18 and he holds up tamiya's
severed head coria orders the second
troop to retreat at once to prevent
muzan from recovering any more of his
strength by eating more people meanwhile
muzan gloats etamio and says that her
medicine to cure demons and turn them
back into humans had failed as the woman
responds that this would be the day when
muzon would finally go to hell the demon
flippantly responds that hundreds of
people had said those same words to him
before but they had yet to come true
tamil tells him to give back her husband
and children and muzan coley looks at
her and says that in that case she could
go and join the family that she had
killed as he crushes her head and his
hands elsewhere in the infinity castle
yoshido immediately falls to the ground
while running as this happens tearing up
on the floor and gritting his teeth and
rage at tamio's death muzan swiftly
makes short work of the second troop as
well slicing through them all in one
move as kara orders for them to fall
back asking about giz whereabouts muzan
says that not one of them was of use to
him as he killed them and declares that
he will end the demon slayer corpse on
this night as he also smirks with an
evil expression karaya ubiyashiki panics
and regrets the great loss of life to
all the demon slayers who had been slain
by the newly reawoken muzan blaming
himself for the failure he begins to
lose focus of what is around him and
continues to fear that he has wasted
years of effort by his predecessors and
all the demon slayers who had given
their lives in their fight against muzan
kanata though slaps him out of this much
to their sister kunawai's shock and
yells at him to keep himself together
and issue his next orders as the battle
was still ongoing realising his father
and forefathers had gone through all of
the same pressure karia recomposes
himself and orders for his
reinforcements to be sent to muzan's
location and to focus their power on one
point to get rid of muzan once and for
all
kanata heads back to her seat and kara
thanks both his sisters for being there
to support him as they both tearfully
accept his thanks a crow announces to
the other demon slayers that muzan has
been revived and passes on karia's
orders for the other hashera together
immediately matsuri is shocked to hear
the news as obanai curses the fact that
he and mitsuri are being held back by
nike may while the others had already
slayed in the upper rank even at the
cost of muchiro and genye's lives
matsuri is confused at the order they
have received and wonders if that means
that they should mess up with the other
hashera and leaves nakime alone suddenly
she is whisked away by the hem of her
cloak by someone as niki may play zubiwa
again meanwhile muzan who was standing
amidst the corpses of all the demon
slayers he had killed is suddenly
teleported into a large room with
tanjudo and geyu joining him
tanjido is shocked to see the demon and
his mind floods with the memories of his
family's murder nezuko is a demon and
all of his fallen comrades enraged he
grips his sword tightly and looks
fiercely at muzan but giu tells him to
calm himself down muzan begins to speak
to them again saying that they are all
persistent and that sickens him to the
bottom of his heart continuing on the
demon says that the demon slayers always
talked about avenging their families or
friends believing that instead they
themselves should just be thankful for
the fact that they had not died and
simply go back to the way that they used
to live their lives tangita was shocked
at these words and asks muzan what he is
saying as the demon compares himself to
a natural disaster saying that no one
saw vengeance on earthquakes or storms
when they killed people concluding that
the dead could not be brought back to
life and that they should all just go
back to earning their daily wages he
says that most humans do that and the
only reason the demon slayers did not do
the same was because they were a bunch
of deviants and he was sick of dealing
with deviance muzan says that he is the
only one who truly wanted the state of
affairs to come to an end as tanjido
comes to a boiling point and says were
they calm seething rage that muzan was a
being that should not be allowed to
exist as tanjulo stares down muzan the
young demon slayer notes to himself how
this is the first time he has ever felt
such sheer rage at any living being
knowing that the demon lord will not be
defeated by simply cutting off his head
and that they will have to drag him out
into the sun to truly be rid of him for
good aiming to stool muzan and buy
enough time for the other demonstrators
to join them tanjulo resolves to get any
information that could prove useful out
of the skirmish to tell the others and
make the task easier for all of them
muzan suddenly swings his tubes at both
tanjiro and giu but the demon slayers
are able to dodge the attack muzan gazes
at his attack taking in his new form's
prowess and then unleashes even more
ferocious attacks at the demon slayers
geu just barely blocks the attack with a
water-breathing 11th form dead calm and
the water hashera notes the speed of the
attacks and also that the tubes are as
sharp as swords tantra was entirely
unable to keep up with the attacks and
dodges them on pure instinct but still
attempts to get through the tubes closer
to muzan he manages to do so but before
he is able to attack muzan the demon
slices at him and manages to cut his eye
giu comes in close to scoop tanjiru up
and away from muzan warning the boy not
to get too close saying that muzan is
far stronger than an upper rank and that
it is best to keep their distance as
beheading mozam will have no effect
muzan asks if three hashera are rarely
enough to accomplish this task the count
takes geyu and tanjudo by surprise as
muzan continues on saying that obanai
and matsuri had already been killed by
his subordinate nakime as he had seen
through her eyes the demon slays dodge
another wave of attacks from muzan and
tanjiru urges himself to not become a
burden now that he has lost an eye
attempting to use his smell to keep up
tangier was shocked as he finds that
muzan's attacks are so fast he's unable
to even smell them finding himself
unable to keep up his breaths tanchodo's
new blind spot gives him a harsh
reminder of the existence as he smacks
into a wall on his right side geu calls
out to the boy as muzan launches attacks
his way suddenly matsuri bursts into the
scene by breaking through the wall
behind muzan and the demon and gilu look
on in shock at the fact that she is
still alive unleashing a love-breathing
sixth form cat-legged winds of love
matsuri looks on dumbfounded as muzan
shrugs off the attack with ease and
doesn't even take a scratch from it
while this happens obernai picks up
tanjuro and orders for him to fall back
instead of being a burden in which
tangier was grateful that obanai and
matsuri are still somehow alive obernai
does a double take in shock telling
tanchiro to worry about himself first
looking on muzon wonders how the
tuashiro he had seemed to be dead could
still be alive he yells in nikime's name
asking what is going on and yushira
responds to him saying that he is
controlling her right now the castle
begins to shake violently as yushiro
yells with tears in his eyes that muzan
had committed the gravest sin in the
world by killing tamio and declares that
he will wipe the demon lord from the
face of the world the heshira battle
muzan but the sight of their battle
repeatedly changes within the infinity
castle and matsuri begins to get dizzy
muzan sniles at them and they love a
share of cows and fear wishing for
gyomei to arrive and aid them saying
that yoshira's plan to have them pretend
to be dead was now in shambles and that
geyu and tangido were in greater danger
than they had realized flashing back to
yushero explaining his plan to her
matsuri recalled how the demon told her
to cooperate with him if she wasn't an
idiot she said to herself that she
wasn't one agreed and you should have
told her to distract nakime so that he
would be able to sneak up behind her and
take control of her mind to show her a
false vision to feed muzan of all of the
hashera being dead so that they would be
able to storm him at once with him being
caught unaware masudi is amazed at this
ability of his and tells him so back at
the battle with mozan the landscape
continues to rapidly change as the demon
lord identifies that yushiro is
controlling nakime he attempts to
wrestle back control of nakimi's mind
from yushiro and manages to weaken the
young demons hold even beginning to
spread his cells to yushiro's hands a
demon slayer next to yushiro offers to
be eaten by the demon to strengthen him
and give him a better chance against
muzan but yushiro fiercely rejects this
notion muzan's attention is suddenly
brought back to the battlefield as giyu
and aguro attack him with water
breathing fourth form striking tide and
serpent breathing first form winding
serpent slash respectively yushira
begins to fight back while muzan is
distracted and manages to have nakime
change the battlefield again leaving
muzan and the hashira falling as he
falls muzan reaches forward and clenches
his fist destroying nakime's skull
sensing that the castle will soon
collapse yeshua attempts to transport
all of the demon slayers out of the
castle before it is destroyed the floor
reappears beneath them all again as the
demon slayers continue to fight against
muzan and dodge his attacks tanjidu gets
hit by one of the attacks and his right
shoulder begins bleeding the castle
begins to creak and obanise senses that
it will soon be destroyed noting that if
it happens then only muzan would survive
as matsuri notices that they are all
being pushed upwards muzan launches an
attack at her taking her completely by
surprise tajiro rushes forward though to
intervene and swings his blade flinging
a demon slayer's broken sword straight
into muzan's head taking the demon by
surprise and infuriating him further the
castle finally stops moving as it bursts
through the ground to the outside
flinging them all to the surface
well that officially brings us to the
very end of the one and only infinity
castle arc of demon slayer if you guys
have enjoyed the video do make sure you
hit that subscribe button and also be
sure to leave a like on the video as
well as it really goes to show that you
do enjoy this kind of content and you
know i'd love to like obviously make
more of these explained videos for
different kind of series in the future
so make sure you leave a comment down
below on kind of like what series
possibly you'd like me to go over i was
possibly thinking chainsaw man next
obviously i've still got one more like
the other i guess latter half to this
arc that i've still got to do so i'll do
that over the next two weeks and then
release it probably in about two weeks
from now and then that'll be like demons
they're finished but yeah if you guys
you know like as i just said if you guys
have enjoyed this video please do leave
a like and if you are new around here
please do hit the subscribe button i put
so much work into this video over the
past three weeks and it is officially
the longest video on my channel now so
i'm super proud of it and i think i've
come along you know like a long way from
when i first did my x-plane kind of
video with the tokyo avengers one so i'm
super happy with how uh this one has
come along i'm sorry that it has come
out a little bit later than i said i
thought i would have been able to do it
a little bit quicker but uh turns out i
i couldn't so yeah of course if you
still are around here thank you to my
amazing patreons and you know also go
and check out my discord if you want to
be a part of that as well as i'll leave
a link to both of them down in the
description but anyway for now it's been
your professional degenerate diavolo and
i will see you all in april
bye
[Music]